welcome to the last word thank you guys
for coming in today
it is a odd episode because lord cognito
is
under the weather um he had a little
little work done uh getting something
fixed in his nose but he
is recovering fine so nothing nothing
wrong there he's just got to recover but
not able to do a podcast but the destiny
world exploded today
and we are joined by an awesome guest uh
you guys may know him from
the new host of fire team chat as well
as the most handsome man in the room
even though i gave it a shot
i failed and we're gonna get this thing
going ty guy travis how you doing man
glad to have you on here for this quick
one
mcclunky everyone and glad to be back
you get to say mclucky here it's the
same mcclunky here
it's it's uh home away from home uh yeah
glad to be back and
uh for those of you that don't know we
we put this together last minute just
because there was so much
news and and ivantas and i were just
chatting on twitter and we're like dude
do you just want to
talk about this we i need to talk with
someone about this destiny craziness
that's happening today
so it worked out because you were fire
team chats doing your you know every
other week
and then we had an off week and i'm just
like in my head there's so much to talk
about i gotta record something i'm just
like i reach out and i'm like
come on thai guy and he's like dude yeah
i was like sweet so
we are here um odd hours for sure but
yeah i've been playing outriders all day
state of play just happened and then
this in the middle and i'm just like
it's a busy day um this is this is what
you get for your heresy ivantos
yeah you leave for time
you leave destiny for one day to go play
outriders
and all of a sudden they pull you back
in
no and that's actually something i
wanted to say is i swear
bungie planned this because they're like
outriders the demos going live
servers are getting overwhelmed and
everything in bungie is like oh don't
forget about
us state of the game like how
do you think that was planned at all i'm
curious
i don't think so but if they did they
took it from wow
maybe they learned it when activision
was their publisher because wow used to
do that all the time anytime like a big
game would come out they would announce
their big expansion and i think
rumor was i think somebody told me who
knows more about wild than i do like
james duggan or someone
someone told me that their strategy used
to be they would develop an expansion
and then they'd just keep it into their
pocket
until a competitor came out and then
they would just plan the release around
this
like new they did they did that when the
star wars the old republic
mmo came out all that stuff they were
just planning it around that and i was
like
that's kind of brilliant and also really
mean it's like me
really took a page it's also like risky
i mean grant it gives them plenty of
development time but at some point you
like we kind of got to put a date on
this thing and blizzard's like
we're just raking in millions of dollars
we don't really have to rush anything
so yeah um i know you haven't played out
riders yet it is fun though i will do
another review about that one and talk
about it more but i've played
most of the day like a good eight hours
uh mostly on that in between other stuff
played a couple classes through the demo
so far it's fun
um it is not a live service game so it's
never going to be the destiny killer so
nobody needs to get that idea but i
think as
a nice you know break between quiet
times and stuff like that i think people
are going to be able to have a lot of
fun
with it about a 35-40 hour campaign and
it does have an in-game grind but it
will have a finale
so that's something destiny does not
seem to have
at all at this point yeah maybe not and
that's how you sell it
saga that was a great that was a great
segue yeah um
yeah so that was one of the first things
that we got um
destiny 2021 update the road to the
witch queen
and what was like the first thing that
kind of knocked your socks off because
you got the first paragraph where
you know joe was talking about his story
to kind of get where he was
and then we get to the witch queen
lightfall and beyond
just like what was the first thing that
was your first like mind explosion
because there's a lot of them today
we're going to go through yes
the first mine explosion was actually at
the header after the first paragraph it
was
and beyond i was like oh so they're
going to talk about beyond
lightfall because i think that was up
for debate and i i think
last week when we got the news that
bungie is expanding at studios doubling
in size and
doubling down on on the destiny
franchise with movies and comics and all
that other stuff they said that they're
going to do
i think that was the point where i said
okay lightful is not the end because
before then i was like maybe it is it's
called lightfall they're saying it's
gonna
bring the light and darkness story to an
end and and also we know that
lots of people on the the bungee team
have been working on this other project
um so you know my thinking was maybe
destiny is
he's on its downward slope and they're
going to give it a finale but as soon as
you got to
the first the announcements last week
and then now this i was just like wow
this is crazy
this is wild they're they're really
doing it well you have like destiny
universe
directors now and then justin got bumped
up to destiny 2's
i guess director of that or lead or
whatever and then
i'm sure joe um who wrote this one
actually is probably some counterpoint
to it is his title on here now actually
assistant game director of destiny 2. so
yeah he's right there second to justin
it seems like
uh yeah i'm with you that was one of the
first things is we'll get to the delay
in a second is just the fact that
from as you said last week the studio is
growing leaps and bounds which is really
cool to see
because it's nice to see a studio like
bungie who does
a lot of positive things for the game
development community between how they
treat their employees their work in the
social space
their continued work like there was the
entire black lives matter post and their
continued work for that
all of those things are really cool and
then you see them like have such success
it's really awesome to see
yeah um yeah and then i i wasn't even
bothered in that same paragraph they say
hey look we're delaying the witch queen
until 2022.
and to me that i kind of glossed over
that there was so much other stuff going
on i was sort of just like yeah i'd not
really care at all
in fact i kind of forgot which queen was
supposed to come out this year it still
feels like it's last year the year
beyond light and we're going to be doing
like
these seasons for a while but you know i
i completely forgot that we were
supposed to get the witch queen this
year so this honestly to me it's not
even really a loss i
to me witchcreen was far away and you
know it was nowhere near
getting released this year so yeah i
mean i read it live on
live on stream while i was like out
writers i was like out writers pause
bring this up
reading through and i was like which
queen is delayed i was like yep expected
that moving on i'd blew past that in a
second because
yeah we kind of all expect with that's
one thing a lot of people are starting
to see now is
last year covet hit but games that
released last year were already
probably fairly close and some things
got pushed but stuff that was like
mid development just got even harder and
they explained part of that is the fact
that
anything that was in development over
the course of the last year
now full year of covid um
they've been working from home for that
much longer so it's harder and harder to
develop content that they're used to
making
at some point to get back in the studio
and they haven't been able to get in
studio to basically touch any of this
stuff so
the fact that it was delayed not a
surprise at all and
they also said i got to read some of
this verbatim because i'm going to get
it wrong if i don't
we also realized we needed to add an
additional unannounced chapter
after lightfall to fully complete our
first destiny saga
that was my second one so we have
beyond light which we thought was beyond
light witch queen and lightfall and
we're like okay that's our package we
don't know what's out here
we now know something is out here and
beyond light almost now feels kind of
like a buffer to you doesn't
that was what it kind of felt like to me
since this seems it always felt like
that to me
okay to be honest like when they were
announcing beyond light and showing the
like what was in it my thought was like
this reminds me of like rise of iron it
and then after playing the campaign i
think
i think we had an episode after i did my
review for ign
and i was like yeah you know beyond
light like it's story kind of felt like
it had nothing to do with anything major
and it seems like they're really
saving their stuff for the witch queen
and even
in uh the season of arrivals i feel like
most of the
uh focus wasn't on whatever was going on
with aramis it was on
the witch queen's arrival it was on you
know like that that was sort of like
what they were setting up so to me
it always felt like it and now this sort
of just confirms that it's not act one
of the final trilogy of the
the light dark and light song it's just
a year in between while they do some
development stuff and i i
i think that's way better so yeah i mean
it sets the precedent for
for one witch queen we know it's getting
delayed and they said
to early 2022 i'd put january to april
as an option at this point because
they say early they didn't say january
i'm gonna give them as much time as they
need
because it sounds like this is gonna be
something special so
as usual from the super mario quote from
all time
you know delay it and i think i think
we'll all i think we'll all be happy
about it now my curiosity i wanted to
ask you and anybody in chat as well
how do you all think they're going to
time and space out the seasons
i hope they don't to be honest i kind of
hope that a break
i kind of hope we get a break to be
honest i've i've always been
a proponent of fewer seasons because it
seems like the seasons we do get are a
little bit under
undercooked uh and and just we end up
with like a little bit of content that
gets stretched out and i've always
thought
why not just do two seasons that are you
know like like we did
destiny year one we got dark below and
we got uh house of wolves and they were
you know they weren't the greatest
expansions in the world but they
they had a raid they had one of them had
an extra mode the campaigns were a
little bit longer they added
a lot of meaningful content that i think
we sort of miss in seasons where they
just add sort of one
very tacked on you know matchmade
activity and and then that's it
um this season is sort of an exception
to that i'm really really liking season
of the chosen but
in the past that we've sort of had to
you know do the armory
uh stuff just all season and that was
not
enjoyable at all so um i i kind of hope
that they just
stretch on the season and maybe fix pvp
would be a great use of their time that
way
pvp could sort of carry them through to
the you know the next big pve dump of
witch queen but
we'll get to what they said about pvp
later it sounds like that's a longer
term project
yeah uh i mean yeah we said that
probably sometime recently with somebody
it's like i'd be a point to where
even just the six month expansion
something substantial
in the middle like you're gonna have
your breaks as i mean there was the
blizzard developer that was like
people are going to leave your game at
some point how do you want them to leave
now right now this season
is actually probably one of the rare
occurrences i'm with you that they've
handled it well they like gave us a big
dump in the first three weeks
and then i would that sounds terrible um
but then you're gonna have yeah it was
worse than i intended that one to come
out but
you're gonna have one strike and then
guardian games because we already got
the master difficulty i figured that was
weeks later
and then we had the quest which was
still sooner than i thought but we have
one strike we have like the seven or
eight you know we have the weekly
challenge however long the story goes
and then we have guardian games and
there's like the guardian game ceremony
which i still wonder if it's going to
tie into lore
but you get most of the activities up
front do as much as you can and you can
pop
in every couple weeks and catch up on
challenges that's probably one of the
best feel if they're gonna do the
seasonal thing i think that's actually
not bad because
people can get most of it out of the way
and then you'll come back in a couple
weeks i'll get some more of the
challenges i'll do this and then do that
as opposed to
feeling like you have to come every week
seems
seems like this one i'm with you has
actually been handled better than most
but i wonder how the rest of the season
is going to feel now
yeah i always do feel like their first
season after the major expansion tends
to be
maybe i miss remembering that which one
was dawn was after the last one
dawn was after the right after the
season of undyne season of dawn yep yeah
so that that my recollection is that
they get progressively weaker
after the main expansion comes out you
know i would have to go through and
actually look to see if i still believe
that but that's what i remember
yeah and so my like my thing
would be you know if this is the
strongest season and then we've got a
few other seasons coming up that maybe
are gonna gradually get worse until you
know the season before
the expansion release we're doing
something horrible like playing gambit
or something i would just prefer
that they do fewer seasons and flush it
out a little bit more
um i also think there's potential like
they could really take their time
with a longer season leading into the
witch queen if the season is sort of
like season of arrivals where it sets up
the the next expansion you know does
like kind of a lead in and has story
implications of
savathun getting ready to make her move
and all that stuff i think that could be
really cool
we kind of already got that in season of
arrivals because that was pretty much
just us playing games with sabathune but
they could they could find some way to
to you know
make that interesting and fun and then
it sort of serves as
as its own like advertisement for uh the
witch queen coming out so
i think that would be really cool um but
yeah i'm sort of you know
don't worry about it don't don't give me
seasonal content
in lieu of you just putting all of your
heart and soul into a witch queen like
make that
expansion the best it can be and it
sounds like bungie's on the same page
so yeah i was like and that's what it's
i think people are just gonna have to
accept like we're gonna have some
substantially long seasons that are
they're gonna be like spread out
take your you know pieces at a time
maybe a month longer even
and but i think i'm with you like when
you have the almighty moment or
you had the traveler get healed and then
the ships take over the director moment
if witch queen is what they describe for
kicking off like what's gonna end this
light and dark saga and this is what
they're really
that almost could be one of the coolest
that we've ever seen
hopefully if savithoon does start
playing with all her dominoes that she
set up
then we'll have to see what those
actually mean
yeah um so excited man
oh like i read through all this there
were a couple things i will say
one of my giant fists so okay so those
were explosions about which queen
random tangent though what was your like
did you have any like hands over your
head like fist pump like big moments
and mine was stupid mine was dumb i know
what it was though
i'm excited to see yours honestly the
whole thing
read like a love letter to the community
and like hey we're here we're gonna like
fix it i know a lot of people i think
the biggest headline to come out of this
was sun setting
um the fact that they're getting rid of
sun setting but to me
it was the fact that they finally
addressed pvp in a meaningful way i mean
they've done that in the past but this
time they sort of were like hey look
it's it's a part of destiny it's not
going anywhere or we're not giving up on
it and then they started to list like
the things they're gonna do
helping with the cheaters they confirmed
one for me that was like oh thank god as
a pvp man
is uh they confirmed that they're not
going to make you be in a playlist with
pc players on console once cosplay
arrives
that to me was like all right thank god
because that was something that's been
in the back of my mind for a long time
like oh god are they going to do that am
i gonna
am i gonna hate this crossplay change
because ideally
i would like to be able to play with my
friends on pc my entire clan is on pc
none of them play on xbox
but i have a lot of friends on xbox and
i'm
that's just where i tend to gravitate to
when i play uh mostly because i don't
like to play with cheaters so i play on
xbox
where it's fair crucible or crucible is
it all palatable
um and uh yeah so that was really cool
but i think for me it would have to be
uh the section where they just talked
about crucible that that to me was like
oh thank god
they like know it's important and
they're gonna fix it and they're
doubling the size of their security team
to address cheating on pc all that stuff
was really cool
yeah my little like moment was shaders
are no longer going to be consumables
and it wasn't really or about that no
it's just like it's a
it's a small but petty annoyance it'd be
like that one and then if paul tassie
would have his explosion if they're like
blues are gonna get fixed that would be
paul's if he actually had one to like
he'd read through and see that and just
happy about it i mean there's
amazing i really don't understand that
one like you just delete him you get a
few materials out of it why do we have
to
i don't understand that but yeah he's
been talking about that on fire team
chat for weeks
i mean i'm with him that's his what what
are you what's the ass bungee or
bungee wish or whatever bungie please
please damn it i had the wrong name but
yes
yeah see i listen you do yeah you do
yeah absolutely
that's been his bungee please for a
while so what just a tangent here what
is the argument against blues like why
why is that a problem uh i mean
depending on your vault space which is
gonna be
an issue which we'll talk about in a
little bit but depending on your vault
space and how much you have on your
character
if you go through like i've been playing
iron banner and i swear i've got four
drops every match i've been just they're
throwing loot at me
so if you play like four or five matches
you just got like 20 blues either you're
gonna break them down
either they're gonna push stuff out of
your postmaster like blues are not
required after a certain point they do
use zero
benefit usually most of the time
so then it's either it usually just
works against you
after a certain point if you could just
either turn off picking them up or just
like
choose and even in playing out writers
it was like auto loot
and it literally has this auto loot a
rarity
and you can choose i only want to pick
up epic stuff and that would be purple
in that game
and you're like if it's blue i don't
want to touch it like you could actually
set that as an option i'm like
that would be nice now the reason i say
postmaster for
vault space is because we'll get to the
point where your stuff's going to stay
around for a while now
yep um yeah that's that's another yeah
that's another
transition segue uh yeah
for me like i i guess i'm a different
type of player my ball
is not at all full because i just tend
to not i'm not like at
all lovey-dovey about my equipment i'm
just like ah delete it all get rid of it
like i don't care oh it's a god rule i
don't care like let's just get rid of it
i mean i'm the exact opposite i'm a
hoarder in destiny i think you're most
people
i think you're most people because a lot
of people seem to have this problem
they're like my postmaster's filled up
and my
items are getting deleted and i'm like
bro i never go to the postmaster
i like this is not a problem i just look
at it on my character and
i go okay stats aren't that good and i
delete it that's it but even like the
ones that go to your character you're
still just delete delete delete for
after like every single crucible match
they helped me level up this season for
the
power or whatever yeah the 50 they're
hoping you level up
yeah they will help you level up there
which has been and that's why i was like
you could choose but say once you get to
1300
now you're done with them those are
never going to help you again so
and and with the new leveling up rules
that they said where they're only going
to be increasing it by 10 and so now
blues are basically going to be
completely relevant i think they might
end up going back to
destiny 1's mechanic of auto dismantling
blues because that was a thing in uh
in destiny 1. or was it greens i i
played destiny 1 recently
and i saw a green engram drop and i
forgot that those were in the game i was
like
like the hell is that i don't even know
what that would look like in destiny 2 i
don't even know if there's a graphic for
that in destiny 2. that's
i don't think there is but yeah and the
driver dropped and i was like i was like
wow that's a green engram i completely
forgot about those
um but yeah for we jumped around a
little bit there but i'm going to try
and work our way through this thing so
the witch queen represents
an important evolution in the ongoing
story of destiny 2. like this is why
when we're talking about like
what's the end of season event for which
queen for 15 however long that thing
takes
beyond light built the foundation and
allowed us to weave the world building
of destiny and destiny 2 together
because they brought back the stranger
of course but light but the witch queen
will light the fire on a strongly
interconnected narrative across
lightfall and beyond unlike anything
we've ever attempted before with
characters arcs heroes and villains that
persist over multiple future releases
even more importantly the conclusion of
these releases will conclude the light
and darkness saga
that's an important line we've got to
come back to the conflict we
first introduced with the launch of
destiny many years ago as we've been
developing the witch queen
we realized that we needed this release
to be the first of many moments
crucial to the story of destiny with so
many so much
leading to and dependent on what happens
in the witch queen we wanted to make
sure that we gave ourselves enough time
to build up the journey right away
uh starting with an exceptional first
chapter in the witch queen so a couple
things to unpack
we've got you know obviously the weight
on which queen seems huge
we talked about that a little bit but it
seems like even more the narrative the
arc the characters though building for
this
and future releases because that ties
into the light and darkness saga wraps
with
what is that going to be year ed is that
going to be year 10 at that point is
that right
yeah they said it was a 10-year journey
so i think they're going to be on
schedule for that
so does it sound like for you after the
light and darkness saga
is that destiny 3 i think
like europe i hope they drop the two
eventually but i don't know we'll ever
get a destiny three i think they might
just eventually drop the two
or it'll just be one of those things
where everybody plays the two like dota
2
like nobody ever talks about dota 1 but
dota 2 is just going to be
the game forever i could see that
happening um
but yeah it's it's i i think so
today it's 2021 destiny launched in
fall of 2014. so
it'll be yeah 2024 you're right it'll be
at the exact
10-year mark before they and i i assume
that that
it's going to be crazy i i bet that they
start killing off like main characters
like
zavala and akora and stuff like that and
it'll it'll just be completely different
by the time we get to
whatever's next for destiny yeah i mean
it seems like they have to do some
drastic things and they've been
leading the stuff because certain people
are whistling which makes you wonder
what savathun's dominoes are gonna do
like is crow gonna be
an important factor in the vanguard ever
or not
so i mean they have all these little
pieces we're all like what are all these
questions and
it seems like they're finally gonna
start leading into those answers a
little bit more
speaking of aikora season 14 she's part
of it
a big part of it a big part of it yeah
so i have no idea how she comes into
play but it's nice to know that they're
actually using her again
because everybody's like dude where's
our girl she's just chilling over there
in the tower twiddling her thumbs
looking around yeah i think people were
getting nervous that maybe the actress
wasn't
wasn't interested in participating or
something was going on i remember
the same things on twitter and read it
but uh this is great because it means
that
she's going to get another day in the
sun and you know
i i think somebody in the comments just
said that they think that they're going
to kill her that was my first thought
too
i was like oh the core is gone like
something's going to happen to her so
it's like she's so busy we have to bring
it's like can we get you back one time
and then we'll kill you when you're good
that's all we need one more i don't know
yeah it'd be
so if you lose so hunter vanguard kade
would be gone
then if we potentially lose zykora and
then zavala is the last vanguard
standing
then there's a point is like is the
vanguard even a thing at that point
yeah i mean they they kind of already
have their new vanguard waiting in the
wings though they've got
their titan in saint 14 they've got
their crow the hunter and they've got
osiris as their warlock they've got oh
kind of their
and they're already they're already kind
of
doing all the vanguard stuff like how
often do we talk to zavala we're talking
to the crow and osiris
more and saint 14 was huge last year so
it's like how how useful is the is the
vanguard right now anyway if they're not
even using those
characters so um
yeah so it's it's really exciting that
i think in the past like two seasons
between beyond light
and seeing the stranger and drifter and
aerys and then this season now
now as we've got saladin coming in and
so much more voice acting
destiny has its ups and downs you have
some fatigue in the game but what has
intrigued me the most of everything
they've been doing besides like the
secret missions those are always awesome
those are some of my favorites
the story has been really cool like the
implications of everything they're
building
has been exciting so to know that
they're diving even more into that
is probably where i'm as pumped as i
could be for
the destiny story because they're
building a bigger and bigger world and
to know it's going to continue after is
i don't even know what they're going to
do i'm just so intrigued
yeah it's like it's very bizarre to
think of a version of destiny where
the fight between the light and the dark
is not the main
concept and i guess i never really
thought it would end i kind of thought
like oh yeah the darkness will always be
like around as a threat
and i'm very curious to see what what
the world without
the darkness and the light looks like in
destiny
and now that i'm thinking about it
they're kind of already
breaking down a lot of the weird like
constructs that have existed in destiny
like for the first time we're
we have an open dialogue with the cabal
like they're just talking to osiris on
com chat for like an
hour just got a voicemail from kyle
what's up kyle
yeah it's super weird so like i could
see a version where you know the
darkness is gone and maybe the cabal or
allies of humanity or you know we're not
all
trying to kill the hive are probably
still gonna be nuts because they're
that's their whole game but maybe they
don't even exist without the darkness i
have no idea what that looks like so
um i think it'll it'll probably look
totally different than what we have now
right
i feel like it has to i also wonder when
we ever get a new race
in the game because everybody wonders
about like
you know the veil and the widower and
all that like rumored stuff that never
came to light
but is that like is this light and dark
still gonna be a cabal fallen hive
and vex for like the next three plus
years do you see us still fighting the
same races for another three and a half
years or do you see them
do you see them you're saving that for
later or bring it in before like a
destiny i don't i don't see them ever
taking out
like a mob out of destiny and i don't
think a lot of games do that once you've
developed an entire faction you kind of
want to keep it in play
like this even the scoring are now
getting their day in the sun again with
you know pressage
that's true uh coming back so i don't
think they ever get rid of one but i
think maybe uh
they need to introduce some new ones
like for sure at some point because
i mean the darkness is i think that's a
lock there's got to be some sort of new
mob for the darkness
at some point and you know they used to
do it
fairly often and destiny won we got the
taken as a new mob which is still the
coolest
mob in the game as far as i'm concerned
and they got added the second year of
destiny so
i think they're going to add more as
they go but i don't think they'll ever
get rid of the ones that exist because
that would just be
pretty unprecedented i actually talked
about last week on fire team chat how
even in halo like once the covenant are
your allies
they you still fight them it's like oh
yeah they're like
an offshoot they're factions of
extremists who just don't
don't like you and so they like give you
a reason to keep shooting the same
enemies
and uh i i think destiny totally goes
that route like i don't see them oh
you're allied with a cabal all right no
cabal you're never gonna fight them in
the game ever again like there's
there's like a zero percent chance of
that happening so yeah i mean
even with like follows the given like
faction house here
house here house over here mythrax is
one that totally we could have like
we could somehow have a i don't know how
you talk to a fallen because i don't
think they speak our language like cabal
do but
mithrax does seem to be an ally to a
point so stuff like that definitely
feels like it's going to be
a thing but yeah i'm wishing with you at
some point over these next three and a
half years we have to see another race
at some point maybe which queen does it
or maybe witch queen just like reinvents
the hive
which going to hopefully reinvent the
hive that's what i'm hoping for maybe a
couple
i hope it gives the facelift to the hive
that
uh destiny 2 vanilla gave to the cabal i
think that would be pretty good
okay remember the cabal were kind of the
most underdeveloped faction in destiny
and then
when destiny 2 came out they added the
war beasts they added the
incinerators there was just like a whole
bunch of stuff that
got added through that so if they could
do something similar or even bigger
that would be great uh but yeah i don't
i don't think we're going to get the new
faction during which queen i think they
wait for lightfall
and they might even wait now now with
the delay they might even wait till the
very last year destiny
uh at least in the the dark and light
saga i hope i hope not but they might
yeah
um and then we also as you go through
this next piece they said they're
committed to
uh being an everlasting evolving world
we want to make sure we are still taking
our time to upgrading
uh our systematic foundation of destiny
2 to support everything we want to do in
the future our ultimate vision for
destiny 2 still stands
a definitive action mmo a glow a united
unified global community where you can
play destiny anywhere with your friends
for 2021 this means upgrading our
approach to keeping destiny's weapons
and armor game fresh and armor my god
needs a refresh
refining your vision for pvp
implementing transmog and adding cross
play more below
uh finally the most important reason
we're proud to be uncommon
compromising when it comes to our
commitment to our health of our teams
and then they just said with copic covid
keeping us away we just need time to
basically make which queen what we
wanted to and we talked about that
already but
that's again bungie doing the right
thing not saying hey this needs to come
out here
it's we're going to take the time to do
it right without
working on people to the bone and we
have to work from home it's just going
to take longer
yep um but
they're like with witch queen being
delayed beyond and late this summer and
all that stuff we still need we talk
about what's happening in 2021
rewards that matter with season 11 we
introduced infusion caps
an iteration on infusion designed to
keep destiny's gear game fresh
from release uh to release and to create
a healthy ecosystem for aspirational
content while we believe in these goals
it's clear
our execution was off the mark
you think i believe everybody would
probably agree
it didn't go as planned now many factors
could have gone into play there even i
was one that in theory
was like okay with sunsetting to keep
things fresh
yeah so was i i mean i think the caveat
i said when it was coming out was and
destin was a huge like
never sunsetter like he hated it forever
and i think i
said like no it could be good because
this gives them a chance to try new
things and make off-the-wall weapons
that they don't have to worry about
balancing
later uh and you know as long as they
don't just keep rehashing the same
weapons over and over again we'll be
fine right
right and then they went and rehashed
the same place over and over again
that was the main trial anything they
were interesting yeah there was whatever
swab there was a the whatever bullet
point started with reissuing and i was
just like
it was that was just a punch to the gut
when it was like oh and they were
talking about uh
this season reissuing weapons four
shattered throne reissuing the moon
and those two pieces and i was like ugh
so they have to regrind for him yeah i'm
like and some people already had those
now
so infusion caps helped us meaningfully
shift the men and beyond light so they
do like being able to shift the meta so
it's not always the same weapons
apparently they really had to just break
the game to get rid of mountaintop
and recluse and people like you could
have just gotten rid of those two
but yep so they have made the decision
that any weapon or armor that can
currently be infused to max power
so basically season of the worthy and
onward
will continue to be able to reach max
power permanently
so if it exists now and can be infused
to this level this season's cap
it will still be able to indefinitely
so that basically says seven serif
weapons are staying around
war mine cells are staying around fell
winter's alive because they're gonna
address that later oh yeah we'll get to
both of those
um but all of that stuff that people
were like this is the last season
there's some big stuff going
not anymore so what do you think
are you i know now that we know that
it's like this season
do you think they could have handled it
any other way first
um could they have handled any other way
i think they had to go back on this
unless they're
unless they were going to prove that it
could work that was always my thing is
like people were immediately against sun
sitting and i said well
you know give a chance to prove it can
work give them a chance to make a whole
bunch of new weapons that blow us away
and i think
when when i like got that pit in my
stomach like oh god this is going to be
terrible
is when beyond light came out and the
loot pool for weapons was like
minuscule it was just so bad and i was
just like holy crap like
that the whole point of this thing was
that you guys said you were gonna
you know refresh the sandbox and instead
you're just taking away the stuff we
like and giving us
old weapons back that we now have to
regrind for every season that was crazy
to me so
i think the way that they deployed it it
was sort of like
they would have had to do a whole lot to
to
to fix it in a in any other way i think
the the easiest way to do it is just do
what they said what they're doing now
right like just
reverse it while you come up with a plan
because i had assumed they had a plan i
guess i was wrong
i just started sunsetting weapons
without any plan on how to like
refresh the sandbox or provide new stuff
for us to grind for like really we're
just gonna grind for the
same old weapons and then we get like
three new weapons per season one of
which we get from the season pass right
away
that's nuts to me like i i don't know
how they ever thought that was a good
plan
no and it's and that's again where i
wonder you know three more years of this
and they continue to make cool stuff
we've seen this season we've got some
cool new perks
uh we've had some fun exotics and
but it's also the point of i went
through my vault and i was like hey
they're telling i literally did this as
like a point of principle i went through
my vault it was like
this has been sunset delete delete
delete delete delete
and i'm like i'm not going to be able to
use this in high level and i'm still not
going to be able to it's like if they
get to the point
so i was what i was saying is if they
did this the right way is
they couldn't have gone back and said
hey the stuff we had sunset if you kept
it still
now you can use it everywhere i don't
think they could have done that you
would have
that you couldn't go that far back on
your word but at this point like
if it's active now it's still good so i
was like i don't think they could be
like hey if it was
once if it was season of dawn weapons
yeah you can bring those back if you
kept them so i think they had to do this
onward
but it is one of those that's i'm with
you it's like how
as big of a change as it was to say
we're going to wipe out 75 of your
arsenal and then we're not even going to
have like a void bow for
a whole season or take stuff out in the
only void machine guns from the raid
like there's
certain pieces that we had a lot of and
now it's not even there
there's a void machine gun in the game
that's blue
there's a rare void machine gun in the
game just so you have an alternative
if you can't do the raid and you want to
avoid blue machine gun or avoid machine
gun i noticed that because i've had like
three of them recently i'm like
why is this a new gun what are you doing
they're still making
blew blues away a little bit blew you
away nice
see what you did there got him travis
on top of his his game there no question
about it though
um and they said well we they said
they strongly believe that destiny needs
a method to shift our meta in the game's
most challenging activities
we don't agree yeah and i agree with
that like the mountaintop recluse
forever meta it gets boring for
everybody i think we
all see the problem they're trying to
solve yep it's just that
not a lot of people agreed with their
idea on how to do it and then the people
who did agree on their idea of how to do
it like you and i like okay fine take
away my weapons as long as i have new
stuff to chase
we could not have fathomed how they were
going to actually implement it or
lack lack of implementation really is
what happened right like they didn't do
anything with it but
yeah i think we all agree on what the
problem is i'm interested to see how
they solve it i don't really have any
ideas
yeah i mean for me the sun setting armor
was probably one of the bigger ones
without a plan
because they've said like hey we're
working on making sure it was whatever
post joe
um joe said before that we're working on
some plans so your armor is not just
a stat replacement of what you had out
last year and i'm like okay that's cool
that's why i was like i was looking up
the witch queen for armor been saying
that for a while that like armor 3.0
coming into which queen cool armor
doesn't matter till then
which is unfortunate transmog even more
so being a factor
but now the weapon piece as you said the
reissues were just like
they didn't have either side covered and
when you finally look back and go
they just hoped for the yeah it was just
a weird decision you know what their
plan was
yeah i really do yeah it's just a big
head scratcher but at this point we can
see
that they are going to be tuning some
things so stuff that is staying around
like fell winter's lie
war mine cells the biggest outliers in
pvp and pve those are going to get
looked at
so warming cell builds now will be still
viable because your seven serif weapons
will be dropping
so now my question is the one for you
everything lasts forever again how's the
world loot pool gonna look
[Laughter]
just bigger and bigger and bigger i
think i think they remove
stuff from the world loot pool they just
don't let they just don't make
you get rid of it so there's going to be
weapons that you had to be there during
that season to get and they'll take them
out of the world blue pool and they'll
no longer be acquirable if you hadn't
already
they're just not going to take away the
ones that you you did get if you want to
keep them
so i see i think that's how they have to
deal with it otherwise the world blue
pool is just
absurd um i mean the only other option i
can say is umbrals if they build like a
full
history of what's available in umbrella
you could go back to worthy umbrellas or
something
maybe or they could they could start
letting you actually use the collection
system that they spent all that time
building
that which i i'd complain about like
every single week
you know they they could just do that
that way my collection tab actually
means
anything and that means that i was going
to say that needs to be a thing with the
exotics now we have random exotics
if the collection system doesn't work
and those quests ever fade away
that needs to be a thing even more so
i'm with you there yeah
i think they should have some currency
that you have to pay
to roll a weapon uh randomly
that you've already acquired or just let
you assign
a okay i've got this one i'm gonna
dismantle it to make it my collection's
version of that there's so many
solutions this problem what's weird is
that
other games already have solved the
problem
yeah and they're just they're just
letting it kind of languish i don't
understand
like what's happening there maybe they
just have other fish to fry but i
i thought that the collections tab was
gonna be like the most
used tab ever in destiny and instead i
almost never go there you know what i go
there for i go there to
unmark all of the dots
mark as red and now you can do that
quicker now yeah that's
literally that's all i want to that tab
to do i never pull anything out of there
unless i need an exotic and i'm too lazy
to go to the vault but
it's just such a weird uh thing if they
could solve that they could solve a lot
of their problems with the world loot
pool growing too big with
uh people feeling like their vault is
gonna fill up yep i was about to go
there vault space which again i don't
have that problem but like
i i do think it's stupid that i have to
delete every cool thing i've ever gotten
and have no way to get it back like i
thought the whole point of destiny was
that it's a collections game
and that we're collecting weapons and
armor and becoming cooler and
i you know it's not ideal to have to
delete stuff
uh but yeah i just i don't have any
sentimental attribute
to me so delete it all
speaking of another thing they're going
to be backtracking on we're going back
to how season of dawn's power
increase worked so we're literally like
hey we're going back all right we're
going back a little farther in time how
things worked
so now we're going back instead of 50
power level grind each season
it's just the 10 pinnacle so that's the
big change there
and they said well we believe this
change will make it even easier to pick
up destiny and enjoy each new season
uh while still allowing us to have a
deep rpg power pursuit when we launch
witch queen
and that's one of those that i'm very
curious how they handle
if they see the deep rpg power pursuit
are they actually gonna switch up like
the power grind how your actual
character feels powerful
do you think they're gonna change the
system that deep
no and i actually think this is going to
end up being a big mistake
uh that they're doing this they their
entire system is
based on tiered power leveling you get
tier one
and tier two and now all of those are
going to be useless and really the only
engram that matters is going to be
pinnacle engrams
and so your prime engrams are now a
useless item unless you
for whatever reason are like way behind
the curve in term terms of power level
uh every every loot drop in the game is
useless except for pinnacle engrams and
i
i cannot fathom why that is a thing like
why are they called pinnacle engrams at
this point then now they should just be
called
i don't i don't know is everything a
pinnacle engram or is everything now a
prime engram and they're just gonna
change
i have no idea how this is gonna work
but i i actually think this is one of
the areas where i was kind of like
that seems bad like i i don't understand
what is the point of raising the cap by
10 see how does that
make no because because they
they just admitted i can bring
everything with me and infuse it to
light the max
light power right so what's why
how does this help i just don't i do not
understand how increasing the power
level makes anybody want to play destiny
i never reach max power any season i'm
just in crucible i don't care about like
doing the raid every week to get max
power i did get max power last season
but on
accident and i've been i've been close
like two seasons i think i've been close
but i'm with you like i never do it i'm
to the point you don't need it no
there's no activities that make you have
to get to max power there's no real
advantage to doing it i just don't
understand what the
what the incentive is or why anybody
would spend their time doing that and i
don't understand why this is a good
thing to add why if if raising 50 power
every season is bad why is raising 10
better yeah explain that to me i feel
like
they what i think they're trying to do
is
some people like seeing the number go up
while it makes sense or not to
me i don't know but some people like
seeing the number go up
now it's going up less so that's kind of
a backwards thing
like i we've said this before and i've
always like wondered what if it was like
the expansion is a big deal you're going
through the story you're leveling things
up you're playing for a while
it's you're going to invest some time in
it so you're likely to see a power level
go up and it kind of
feels good for an expansion but the
seasonal stuff
you know one day i can't do a grand
master or you know i can't do a high
level nightfall the next day
or i could the next day i can't that
doesn't feel good because you lose the
artifact and then it goes up 50.
so now it's just tinned so now it's like
the grand master gonna go up
it's it's really bizarre to me too i'm
with you i don't
i don't know if 50 didn't work
10 was not liked beforehand so i don't
know why they're going back because that
was like
well this doesn't feel good okay let's
change it okay this is
not we don't like the whole heavy grind
but we didn't like the
just if you want to add stuff like they
added battlegrounds this time around
cool they're a fun activity there's
something new in the game they add some
story to it
and then you can add an exotic quest
that could be at a high level but you
don't just have to grind for it
and i think it truly is they're trying
to find ways to extend play time
that's the only thing i can come up with
is pinnacle what i know our pinnacle is
going to be plus twos are they all going
to go down to plus ones again like they
used to be
is that gonna be a thing just to make
sure like your
time in the game because that i think
because right now they're actually
getting somewhat away from that because
the seasonal challenges will say
hey you can play week one two and three
come back on week seven
catch up on four five and six and i was
like i'm cool with that i like that
because i'm gonna take a break play out
writers
couple weeks come back i can still catch
up on what i missed
that's not a big deal but then this
whole
ten power cap i know you were like
you're
you're joking that you're like i don't
understand why and the more i talk
myself in a circle i don't get it either
i don't know how this
i don't know how this makes it better
being as we already knew it didn't work
once
yeah we know it didn't work once and you
said some people like to see the number
go up who i i want to meet someone who
i don't know anybody who likes to see
the number go up like literally
like i believe you when you say that i
just don't know any of them like who is
out there going
yeah i kind of like it when the number
goes up every season because then i have
to
play the same activities over and over
again and hope for random drops to raise
my level and then i just use those drops
to infuse the equipment i
already have to bring it up to an
arbitrary new power level
i don't know i need to talk to somebody
who likes that and explain to me why
why it's enjoyable for them because to
me it's just a number i largely ignore
until i literally
have to oh you want to do the the
highest nightfall activity all right
well you
literally have to be max power okay okay
i guess then i'll
i'll finally do it so i just don't get
it
yeah like i would like yeah you said
somebody in the comments there so i was
like
yeah please we i really seriously want
to know travis read this
if you want adept weapons don't do
trials if you
if you need the light level for gm
nightfalls
i don't know who david is giving you a
hard time
all right if you want adept weapons oh
and don't do
true and don't do trials you need the
light level for gm nightfalls
okay so that is why you need it to get
adept weapons
but why is that a thing
yeah like they didn't raise the power
level then you would just have to do
master nightfalls so they're
they're giving you an arbitrary power
essentially a time gate
on when you can chase adept weapons if
you're in the pve community i don't
understand how it helps you
well i was like we already have the art
of the reset every season
if they want that with the artifact so
you're going to be like oh i can get
plus 10 more and the my artifact might
get up to 20.
so if that's their way they want you to
put time in to say hey you need to be
able to do a master nightfall
so what are we right now we're 13 60
would be pinnacle cap
so if next season was 1370
then they'd just take everything in the
game and bump it up 10. so then you just
account for what you do with the
artifact grind
plus your pinnacle grind so then if a
master nightfall is like 13
20 bad math but something like that it's
like a couple above so it's just going
to slowly tick up so you still have the
artifact which
i don't enjoy that either to be
completely honest like yeah i don't i
don't get the artifact still
it does allow me to care even less about
my power level for my equipment
because i can still reach whatever max
power is without actually leveling up my
equipment so i guess that's cool but
i i also don't get the artifact except
for that it gives you
seasonal mods which i think is really
smart and maybe there's a way to do that
for equipment too
where if they want to add another
recluse or mountaintop they attach it to
something that goes away at the end of
the season and they don't have access to
it anymore and they can kind of
segment their sandbox between stuff
that's here to stay forever and stuff
that we know that's broken and it's sort
of
gonna have to go away because here's the
thing with sun setting now being gone
i don't think that's real i think some
things are gonna get sunset they're
gonna make
something that they're gonna have to
pull out of the game or nerf it until
it's basically not the same weapon
anymore so
it's not like they're agreeing we're
never gonna take something out of the
game they're just saying
we're not going to make it part of our
process that all
weapons you know see the the end of
their life cycle which i
i think is smart but uh you know
if if if they make another super broken
weapon they're gonna have to address it
bottom line i mean they talked about
fell winners and stuff that's already an
outlier so if they experiment
and it gets too far they are going to
bring some stuff down i totally get that
somebody was saying that's like you know
and that's
i guess what they i would like to see
them do for some of you like seeing the
number up use the artifact as that if
that's what you want
because that's just like time in the
game
doing whatever you want to do versus
like this random
i gotta go here and do this one activity
to do this now do i like having to spend
x number of hours in the game doing
bounties and stuff
just to be able to get like high enough
so a master nightfall doesn't kill me
that's not great either i would much
rather and when they talk about a deeper
rpg
i would much rather go into strikes and
then go into
you know nightfalls at hero level and
get some gear that's like slightly
higher power or does a little bit more
damage
like a real rpg that's where i want them
to really go
and i don't know if they're gonna get
there but that's the part
that's where i wanna see the grind it's
like hey we've got some stuff that's
like
well these guys are a little harder to
hit because it's master okay well i can
go get my armor that gives me a little
more damage mitigation
and also come over here and get weapons
that do more damage not based on this
arbitrary power level number
because that whole number does tend to
feel old i feel like we could beat this
to death and we already have
but yeah yeah we already have but yeah i
kind of agree with you there's like
there's like this weird thing where the
the grind
the grind is based on a number that you
have to get
rather than the content it's associated
with so like in most video games if you
want to do the endgame activity the
grind is
do all of the stuff before it and then
you unlock that activity
but in our game it's like no no you're
you you finished all the story content
the first three hours of the dlc what we
need you to do
is we need you to go back and play old
content
for hours and hours and hours until your
equipment gets up to a certain level and
then you can go into this end of the
game activity and actually achieve it
and that to me is like
bonkers like i don't understand why
yeah but but anyway yeah we've been
missed to death there's definitely a
progression
it's true like that's been the nice
thing about last six months or so like
i've been
trying to play other things i've been
getting away from destiny like i'll get
my time in and i'll play other things
streams have been seeing it's like
you play something like demon souls you
level up and you're facing things
that's one thing about destiny for me
and i know they do it for some balancing
but in destiny you literally never feel
powerful
you can feel weak a lot of places but
you can still die everywhere
you don't ever get to feel mega strong
like there are some games you can
if you put your time in other games you
literally get to feel powerful and in
destiny specifically
the highest level content your artifact
is kept
so then you get to that point the people
who put the most like when i saw
somebody on twitter they were like their
artifact was like plus 62 or some
asinine number where they have you know
millions and millions of experiment
experience in there
i always wondered why because it does
use zero good at the top level stuff
they have the delta where like if you're
20 above everything it doesn't do you
any good
if you're a grand master you could be
1360 right now but if the grand master
is going to cap you at a certain point
i think for me at the biggest piece of
witch queen has got to be the leveling
system that i hope to see them do
something and i think that ties into the
armor because
the armor has to change too and we'll
get into that
but before we get there we got to talk
about your favorite topic
pvp let's
go let's go let's go
uh they said it's a simple vision but
it's one uh they said direct player
versus
com direct player comp versus
competition is essential in destiny as
an
option to express mastery of your
guardian and showcase the strength of
your arsenal against other players
now that is a legit statement that i
approve of
and you also seem to pray to the
crucible goddess
i pray at the altar of shacks uh yeah uh
i i love that um because it is sort of
just a mission statement and what that
says to me is like
hey this is still a part of our vision
for destiny which i think is what a lot
of people were
wanting to hear it's not the first time
they've said this and you know before
when they did like season of the
worthy uh and they were like hey this
season's all about
bruce crucible there were people like me
that were like yes they haven't
forgotten about us but
over time the tendency has been whenever
something goes wrong
with crucible rather than trying to fix
it like they're very good about doing
with pve
they just drop it like when trials
doesn't work
they just go trials is cancelled like
that's how they that's how they
that's how they solve it when trials is
bad is like
it's cancelled we're not gonna fix it
it's canceled and that is i think the
problem
likes even season of the worthy was just
like god dude this mode isn't working
and bungie knows it but like
and they even said like oh yeah trials
has been gone for a long time because we
really wanted to like
make it good once it came back and then
it wasn't and i was like i kind of don't
believe you i don't believe that you put
that much time into this
so yeah i mean i i in bungie's defense
like
i cannot imagine how hard it is to
balance a
competitive pvp you know sandbox
with a game that is so pve and has so
many weapons and so many pieces of armor
it's not halo where there's 14 weapons
and one set of armor it's all these
different factors that i can't even
imagine how hard it is but um
you know a lot of a lot of uh people
like myself that play a lot of crucible
we do feel like we're
second class you know it's not it's it
it's not what the game's about it it's
sort of it's something that they they
added on and
um i've i've felt like they've given up
on it ever since they took
vehicles out of crucible like that was
destiny one days
literally when they took vehicles out of
crucible i was like all right yeah they
they gave up because that's like a
mission shift that's like they were like
hey destiny's gonna be like halo like
you can get in a tank you can
do all the it's gonna have this fun like
interplay between ships and
people on the ground and then they took
that away and i was just like oh they're
stripping it they're stripping it for
parts and
it's felt like it it felt like they've
been stripping it ever since and there's
been some parts where it goes up
they introduced trials and it was like
okay cool now we're getting something
but it
they've never really put a lot of time
into it and you can tell because
there's so many things that have been
broken for so long and crucible
skill based matchmaking was part of
crucible for years and they didn't fix
it
they took out trials of the nine because
they said that
it wasn't that good and then they they
never replaced it i mean how many times
they didn't replace it for years i mean
how many times does that happen with the
piece of pve content where they go
hey this isn't working so we're going to
remove it and we're just not going to
bring it back it's just going to be gone
forever
right like that's never happened to a
raid they weren't like oh
you know what people don't really like
the leviathan raid so that's gone we're
just gonna take it out
like that didn't happen that's never
even been an option of course not it's
never even been on the table and so it's
it's crazy to me that
that it's such a big part of their game
and there's entire community around
people that really like to play crucible
and they've never really put their time
into it so i'm i'm just excited to hear
them say it again
to give it another try they're actually
putting the resources
into uh you know solving the pc cheaters
problem which is huge
uh yeah yeah man i like i i just i like
destiny
i want to play crucible i
you know i i just i'm glad that they
they said that and that i couldn't have
been more happy this was my fist pump
oh i mean i believe that when i reached
out i was like i know i've got my
crucible guy
in the podcast today for sure so for
sure
yeah incognito travis has got you 100
uh i mean even in chat though you're
like you know a serious pvp bit like
somebody's like could you have mentioned
a couple maps as well
it wasn't in there it wasn't in there
yeah that's true
i mean so they say a couple things they
have the simple vision
and they said uh when it comes to
balance updates they're dividing them
into three major buckets
first in season 15 and this is one of
those things that for me
season 15 could be six months from now
late and then they have the delay uh
we'll be addressing three peaking so for
those of you in trials that don't like
three peaking you better get comfortable
it's there for a good
however long this season through may and
then however long the next season is
it's in 13 and 14.
it's gonna be there for a bit i'll be
honest i think people are whiners about
three peaking i
i actually don't even think it's that
big of a deal but i there's people who
are really really
mad about it like oh you're cheating
with a third person short
i do agree with bungie's statement that
it's not the way their game was meant to
be played
right that 100 makes sense to me it's
like if you're
if you're you know doing using an emote
or carrying a sword with no ammo just so
that you can use three person to see
around
a corner like yeah that's not really how
it was intended but
in terms of like people actually being
like oh if you three peak you get like
in it it's like
anybody can do it it's not like they're
doing anything it's like they're
why don't you worry about them hacking
the game and giving themselves
instant res is like that's a way bigger
problem
why are we even talking about three
peaking that makes sense to me as
data when you talk about like the
packing hacking is
being a big thing i know they are such a
data-driven company
and i can't tell you how many people i
follow on twitter
both sides of the spectrum and destiny
but a lot of pvp people are like
i played against this person it's like
95 accuracy 5.0 kill death ratio like
can't you have somebody just like in a
spreadsheet be like if you fall above a
certain line
sort your spreadsheet above here you're
not doing
so right and it's just kind of one of
those that's like
how how is that stuff not a standout and
somebody be like uh
well you don't miss we may not be seeing
it but we're gonna go ahead and uh
put like somebody on you or reviewing
game something to be like
those aren't real shots or something
like to see if they're statistically out
of there because they live off data they
have
always talked about like if you made an
auto rifle adjustment by like 0.12
or whatever that was a long time ago
when they joked about that update
like they they have the data to look at
you know you have a 5.0 kill death ratio
in trials and or
every time you're down one to four you
come back and win every match
yeah there are certain things just as a
data person you can go through and be
like yeah somebody in there can do the
analytics and i know
somebody probably has done that and
that's the unfortunate part
so i wonder where the disconnect is in
even just by data
to not give people like a temporary ban
maybe they're just really hopeful
maybe they hope that there's somebody
out there with a 24.0 kd who's just a
god tier never misses a shot
he never shoots unless he's really sure
he's gonna hit okay he just takes that
extra time put a little jojo on it right
yeah but he's looking over here and the
guy's over there and he dies
[Laughter]
you never know i've i hey i've had a
crucible match where i had like a
20-something kb
20.0 because because i didn't die you
know everybody has like a lucky match
where they just don't die and get a
bunch of kills
but on average what do you what would
you say your katie is probably on
average i know it's better than mine but
i'm scared it's terrible really no
mine's
mine's awful because i i go into
crucible to experiment with weapons
yeah i like i don't play crucible i have
two modes i have
i'm just playing around and trying out
weapons and experimenting and i have
i'm gonna get sweaty when i'm when i'm
sweaty i'm good like i
i you know have three 4.0 kd a lot of
times
but when i'm just messing around like it
varies so much like
people people who look me up like my
stats they'd be like what this guy
this guy sucks at crucible because how
is he beating me right now
yeah yeah and i also like i let for i
let like you know my girlfriend use my
account
and stuff like that there's just a lot
of like stuff like that so basically
what you're saying is you're sandbagging
so your stats aren't out of whack
so your matchmaking your match make you
just want to be low in that matchmaking
pool so you can make yourself feel good
i see how
kind of kind of accidentally i'm doing
that yeah i just i
and the other thing is that uh if you if
you actually try to complete quests
in uh destiny it will ruin your kd
like i sort of just gave up on trying to
have a high kd because it's like
oh right now in iron banner i'm my
entire play style is focused around
getting power ammo so that i can get a
couple power
power ammo kills can we talk about iron
banner there for a second please
please please let's talk about it this
quest man i'm still
on the second quest step to get those
power weapon kills yeah that probably
took me ten matches i might have got one
an average of one a match there was one
match i got two at the same time i was
like
yo and then the next match i got zero
and i was like oh
and this is i forget who i think it was
fallout or tassie or somebody was like
isn't this like the one thing we asked
not to happen and it's back like paul
yeah yeah it was because i i think i
think bungie even addressed it they were
like hey we realize people don't like
power
weapon kills as a requirement on a
mission and then
i guess they have a short memory it's
back i mean this is just like the
the 10 power level thing we were talking
about season of the dawn it's like
they're repeating mistakes now they've
been around for so long it's funny
but yeah when you talked about like the
stagnant nature of pvp iron banner's got
to be the worst defender because since
destiny
2 came out hasn't changed now i will
okay
hasn't changed isn't completely right
they slightly adjusted how control works
with the locking of the points
so you can have yes and they they
adjusted the way the reward system works
yeah
so like those were changed but i mean
we're getting armor from year one
we're getting yep so like your trials
armor we got some cool looking trials
armor this season but iron banner hasn't
seen a new set of armor in
i don't know how long uh the mode hasn't
got much
they haven't brought back anything like
rift they haven't done
i mean hardly anything so if you're if
you're if you're gonna do reissues
everywhere else in the game why wouldn't
you reissue
the cool iron banner armor from destiny
1. the fire in the chest
like dude yeah or the the night armor
where my titan looked like a dope
glorious knight with the nice uh plumage
on his head that was so cool and i i
don't know why that they wouldn't just
re issue that stuff that you can't get
in destiny 2 but you're right like iron
banner
is one of those things where it's like
every time it comes i know i'm going to
do it because
i wanted i want to do it at least once
you know per year per season if they've
got new weapons and equipment i want to
finish it but
i never really look forward to it it's
comp without the sweatiness of
actually playing comp and it's the uh
you know terrible quick play matchmaking
system
and the craziness of that i do like that
there's a lot of casuals in it i have a
lot of fun with that but other than that
like you know it really needs to get rid
of i cannot remember who said they were
on
here on the podcast and they were like i
like being the raid boss
the first oh it was mercury's he's like
i like being a raid boss
in iron banner the first times it comes
around because he levels up so much so
every time he's just like
you know just stomping all over
everybody the first time through and
that's the thing about iron banner
that's where power level actually
matters
and it's one of those weird ones where i
go to shoulder charge somebody
and i almost don't kill him and then i
can't and then i die and i'm like
oh yeah that's in effect you could be a
little higher than me like this one's so
quick there's not a lot of that that
i've run into
but usually about the second one in the
season if you're not doing the pinnacle
grind
and again that's that weird thing with
the power grind like depending on how
many pinnacles you go after
are you going to be those couple points
your luck of if you get good drops i
i have notoriously bad luck in destiny
and everything
shout out to my people still searching
for isa tomorrow um
but yeah like i i just have bad luck at
all that stuff and i'm actually usually
on the wrong side of the power grind in
trials and iron banner like
because i just do crucible it's like
some most seasons i would say it's not a
great way to level up just doing
crucible
unless you do the raid three times a
week and all that stuff like all you
crazy pve people do
uh you're sort of just like all right
i'm gonna be a little bit behind the
curve but at least you know i've got
skill on my side so maybe i'll
be able to be competitive but yeah i
hate that
i mean that's the thing about the
expansions too generally we're gonna get
one raid
this year we get two we'll talk about
that in a bit but
especially that as well it's like you
know oh what's the best way to level up
run the raid again and again and again
and it's like wow the raid's cool i
don't mind doing it sometimes but
i get yeah the whole power grind is yeah
we'll see but
uh they also said they're going to look
over the same everything comes back to
the power grind
it's yeah that i i'm hoping the witch
queen really changes that up because
that
i think that's the one you see people
like hey the season feels great
but the power grind is like the big
giant asterix at the end of everybody's
comment about this season the
battlegrounds feel pretty good
lots of perks on weapons you've got the
new quest coming out but the power grind
it always feels like it's there
so big giant pixar sized booty out there
uh so then we've got across season 13
and 14. so current season and 14 they
said they're going to be adjusting
stasis in crucible in order to bring its
overall effectiveness
in line with our light subclasses here
are some of the changes to expect
behemoth titan sad for us decreased
super damage reduction
increased super energy costs when
performing light attacks so you can't
fly around
remove the freeze from the aoe on the
cast
and reduce traveling efficacy of shiver
strike winds slowed
that's a lot is a lot it's also i think
titan's got the most nerfed but to be
fair
they haven't managed to got that early
warlock's got that early stasis nerf and
no one uses that subclass anymore so i
think it's
probably fair revenant hunter decreased
withering blade damage and tracking i've
heard some people say that like why is
it 91 damage and you have two of them
so that one makes sense i've heard
pretty high pvp people talk about that
decrease the slow stacks applied to
targets and also remove shatter dive
damage reduction
completely now it was reduced before and
now it's
nothing so i guess you'll be a little
easier to kill while you fly through the
air i'm not that good but maybe cheaters
can kill him now i don't know
there you go uh for the shade binder fix
a bug where the ice flare bolts wouldn't
track towards targets immediately on
creation
the stuff that i saw the new ice flare
bolts were so broken it's just like he's
right here and he's like
nope i'm not gonna fire at him did you
see that type
where it was broken yeah yeah so there
is this actually a buff
to stasis class then they're buffing
that they're buffing them
underwater so that it will yeah
everybody gets a debuff
they increase the buff once as usual
they take the warlock thing they nuke it
into the ground
do some other things and then finally
bring the warlock thing back up like
they do with nova bomb
or uh nova warp yep uh decrease the
crystal shatter damage just
everywhere in pvp it seems
and uh fix a bug where shade binder
super projectiles
were not tracking until a certain
distance was traveled so
i guess if you're right next to me i
could miss
yeah i don't play warlock so don't know
right that's right so it's called that's
yeah gotta blur we're two titans in here
we're too uh we're too biased in our
opinion that's right we're brewing it up
today aren't we
i mean you know titan chat didn't bring
my crayons
it's too bad forgot mine too
probably because i ate too many all
right four seasons
for season 15 we're looking also at a
universal adjustments to stasis by
increasing damage reduction
when frozen to provide more
survivability to the victim
i mean i guess that helps some but also
if you're frozen you're still frozen so
you're still kind of a sitting target so
i don't know if it's going to change
that much maybe in like you know one of
those moments where somebody saves you
they might save you a little quicker or
actually be able to save you i guess
yeah i'll be honest i don't i still
don't really even understand how the
stasis
rules work now i feel like sometimes i'm
frozen for like one second and i'm like
okay that wasn't that bad
and then other times i'm frozen for like
five and i'm like what is happening why
am i frozen for so long
uh i i don't really understand how how
that works out but
yeah it's they
i don't know how you fix stasis in pvp
man i have no clue
they got so much closer with now you
only getting frozen for two seconds but
you're still
frozen for two seconds they might as
well just make grenades instant kill
if this was the d1 sandbox where a lot
of things were one-hit kills
like shoulder charging and sticky
grenades or one hit kills and all that
i think it would be a totally different
conversation because then you'd go oh
well stasis is worse you know you have
to not only get the hit to freeze them
but then you have to hit them afterward
to kill them
that would be different but in d2 where
nothing's a one-hit kill it sort of is
like
why like it you're just too many things
are one that kills essentially if you
could freeze them so
i'm glad that they're addressing it yeah
and then they also said following stasis
tuning they will also focus on light
subclasses
and release a set of targeted buffs to
our most underutilized specializations
um our sledgehammer could use a little
work for example
yeah because i never use that i i can't
think of the last time i used that i
thought that was in the game
right i forgot it was in the game it's
taught literally or bottom i was talk
i was talking about how titans didn't
have a
throwable melee and somebody was like
what about the little hammer and i went
it like blew my brain i was like i
forgot that was in the game
like i forgot that that was even in the
game it's so funny
i mean that's that's our subclass and
that tells you how much little how
little we play it being is it something
we should know about and you smooth
forgot that tells you how
little it gets used i i also forgot that
the the
the subclass that i was most excited
about when uh
forsaken was coming out was the one
where you're the commander with the
shield yeah you can buff
bullets that go through your shield and
you're you're kind of like the leader i
was like dude that's so cool i'm like a
nerd for
support classes with the titan i was a
bubble titan in d1
and just like love that concept and then
uh i
forgot i like literally i never use it i
just use the bubble like i
i've i think they nerfed it or they made
it stop stacking with
well and so nobody wanted to use it
anymore like yeah they did something
where just but i remember
for a while that was hot like people
were using it as like strats for
damaging bosses and stuff and i was like
this is awesome
i'm going to be captain america forever
and now i just don't
couldn't tell you anything about that
class i haven't used it in so long the
only thing i used it for was when trying
to work on like soloing
um zero hour the void grenade on the
tank says it would continue to take
damage you'd have your grenade recharged
by the time the tank was dead
that's the only main piece besides what
you're saying in the buff
but it's the only thing is like having
the grenade and the chain explosion
that's the other piece the grenade chain
explosion like one and you get like 10
people explode almost like cosmology
that's the cool part about it
but yeah as you said it's yeah it's
still some people said it's still superb
in gm's
so with ursa furiosa you can get about
50 of it back
it has some benefit apparently but yeah
it's for me it's still i never seen
anybody use it and it's definitely not
like a meta in
it's never part of a strat for like a
raid or anything like that it's just
sort of
no you know which is what it should be
they'll be like it should be able to do
enough enough of a buff so that you
should be able to do the same dps with
five people you could do a six
now something like eight tracks you're
never gonna use it but that's a whole
different story
yeah uh finally they want to continue to
adjust weapon archetype performance and
introduce new
perks that shift the meta and crucible i
think the team has done a great job in
this area over the last several months
introducing balance changes uh both at
the seasonal boundaries and at the
mid-season
and we want to continue to drive down
this path to diversity
to diversify the types of loadouts you
encounter from season to season
in addition at season 15 we'll also be
looking to adjust overall
ability usage rates to make sure gun and
gun play are always key to success in
crucible
i wanted to get your thoughts on that
because that's one thing i've heard a
lot of places that it's
the guns have been in a pretty good
place but the abilities
are so prevalent you don't really get
that much gun play in the first place
yeah i'd say i agree with that um the
first strat
for like any encounter if you're getting
ready to like face off against
people in crucible especially trials
where it's a little bit more tactical
and
and kind of cautious less like
less like uh nuts like just iron banner
free-for-all where you're not even in
the same party with people
uh or you know voice party um
is is the fir the go-to is like how are
you gonna use your abilities right
people use those stasis grenades that
yank you out of cover now
that's like a you know probably the most
popular strat or they'll
throw a knife or a uh a ninja bomb
where it puts the smoke everywhere
they're always trying to come up with
some
strategy to kind of like start off kick
off the the gun encounter and then the
guns are always kind of just secondary
like
hey this is how we finish the job the
exception to that is like
people who are just cheesing bastion or
just you know sliding around with the
shotgun
uh but i would say that if it if it's
not that like how often do you see
people just like peaking each other with
pulse rifles and one of them isn't
trying to like throw a grenade or
something like that i mean
i mean casuals like me running around in
random control sure you'll see that
every so often but like high level stuff
probably never
it's not just doesn't come down to
gunfights it's like can this grenade
pull
one person out that everybody team shots
and then you're at an advantage and then
just start going crazy and it's
like yeah yeah so guns but that's so
weird is that like
finally that people a lot of people will
say the sandbox is in a decent place
generally for a lot of guns now hand
cannons still have their popular loose
their use
and again like 120s are pretty crazy
right now um
but overall guns shotguns
are dominant yeah i mean phil winters
isn't going to do it too they ever won't
be
i don't know if they ever won't be
dominant shotguns yeah i mean
rifles yeah you're right they're um but
yeah i mean shotguns for shirts
and that's again like playing corners
and stuff but when people have the
mobility that they do to pair with a
shotgun
destiny is built around mobility and
especially things like the slides and
the dashes and like
the warlock mobility some sometimes i'm
a standard astounded how much a solar
warlock can move
and how quick the dashes and stuff that
they have when i'm sitting there as a
titan i'm like i feel like i'm stuck to
the floor
depending and again mobility is where
the skill ceiling continues to rise for
high level people
because those are you feel very slow
when you watch a good person play
because they're
moving so fast and in so many different
ways i'm just like trying to focus on
you know aiming decently down a hallway
and trying to hit my shots and they're
in the air flying sideways doing their
shots from there i'm like
yeah that's another level so i mean it's
it's i got to play with aries and
cammy cakes and just listening to them
play
i was backpacked for sure but listening
to them play it's just like it's another
level
it really is which is cool to see that
that much skill is able
like you could learn to be that good
over time you could work on being that
well but it's also
it's a different level sometimes which
is always fun to watch
yeah i've been told i'm like a titan
that plays like a hunter because i slide
and hop around
constantly you know i mean that's what
you that's what you should be doing from
what i understand yeah you just don't
see a lot of titans that play that way
organically
well thank you for holding up the banner
for us we appreciate it hey man
yeah i don't eat crayons i actually read
the lore and i uh
jump around in crucible and you know i'm
making us proud
over here you you're you better than me
i had like a couple a couple okay plays
with them most the time i was like all
right i'm just trying to follow somebody
staying here and try and help team shot
it's all i was trying to do but yeah
communication i mean
yeah i was almost better dead a couple
times just like as i could tell them
where they were
sometimes it helps um they said of
course gameplay balance only matters
when the underlying playing field is
fair
and unfortunately cheating continues to
be a significant issue especially on pc
uh so they said they're aiming to nearly
double the size of bungie's game
security team this year reflecting on
our long-term commitment to fair play
we've begun regular surveys to better
understand your experiences with
cheating and to measure our progress
this new data enriches our existing
streams from
player reports thank you for reporting
um
we begin a strat we we've begun a
strategy of aggressive legal action
against cheat developers
you may have seen news articles of some
of our early actions here we will
continue to pursue those
who undermine fair play using every tool
at our disposal
both in partnerships with our studios
and under our new flag
uh and then they say we'll share more
news on security when they can they're
working on it but they're never gonna
you know show their hand per se just
like in poker but they're gonna try and
at least
they're trying to show that they're
working on it but a lot of people are
like anti-cheat
would you how because i mean you have
what valor went like almost literally to
the kernel of your pc
like how much of an anti-cheat would you
be comfortable with to have a
like quality game of destiny how much
would you be okay with
um
it's a good question
i don't really know the answer i guess
i'm i'm used to
i avoid pc because i know it's sort of
the wild west and that's my ex
that's my expectation i think people who
play pc kind of assume that they're
they're they're like yeah this is the
wild west and i agree to the terms of
of that otherwise i would have you know
bought a playstation
um but
i don't really know i think i think i i
don't know if there's i don't know if
there's a way to win the fight against
cheaters on pc
you know to me it's like a never-ending
battle first off
it's a never-ending battle you know
they're always gonna be back and uh
there's not um there's not one fun thing
that a pc gamer hasn't tried to make
unfun like that's
basically their that's their
their philosophy uh sometimes a crucible
i don't really know i guess um
i guess because i'm a console guy my
philosophy would be like yeah
do whatever you need to like get in
there let them if you're if your game
isn't a game that's designed to have
mods
for example this is a live service game
so absolutely it's not like you see
people
you know dressed like tommy the tank
engine uh
in in destiny because of mods so if your
game isn't made for mods then just lock
it down i'd say but i think one of the
i i give pc people a lot of crap but
like one of the things that is beautiful
about pc is that it is kind of the wild
west it's an open platform and you can
see crazy stuff like mods in it
but i think there's some games where it
hurts more than it helps
and i i think destiny is one of those
games where like you don't want players
tinkering around with the the the way
the game performs and that sort of thing
so i i think uh i i think they should
just lock it down do whatever they need
to do
to just make sure that tutors can't get
away in there i mean do you think they
would ever go dedicated servers
um because that would be one way to
counter it theoretically
yeah i was under the impression that
destiny uses
some sort of technology that makes use
of dedicated servers you're going into
their server when you play
um but i know that they use peer-to-peer
for matchmaking
maybe i don't know enough about the
technology here but i remember reading
something similar well let's say it's a
hybrid combination of both depending on
what activity you're doing
they do something that involves
dedicated servers but
i trust that if if it was as easy as
like oh let's get dedicated servers they
would have done that already
i mean activision had like big pockets i
i
i feel like that can't be
how easy it is to solve the problem but
again i i don't want to be an armchair
developer like this is one of those
things where i say
i think they should make it a priority i
think they should do everything they can
to stop the cheating
on pc so that i can play with some of my
pc friends
uh that won't join me on console but um
you know i'm not gonna pretend like it's
an easy problem to solve or
they're not actually trying it i i'm
more concerned with like
the problems that they aren't trying to
solve in pvp you know like
the fact that they haven't added a map
in like a year or
however long like those sorts of things
where it's just like all right well
cheating is a big problem but i play on
console i avoid the problem altogether
like
like why is it that they don't care
about crucible period like
is is the fact that cheaters haven't
been addressed a symptom of the fact
that they just aren't putting their
priorities in pvp or
you know what's the issue there so yeah
when you see cheaters in gambit you're
like what are you doing
but that's a whole other thing uh i
can't believe people are doing that
that's so crazy
i still blows my mind i'm like you what
why don't people do in raids
is that a thing i guess we just never
hear of raid groups that cheap i mean
i feel like the well they said they
would like
do their like data analysis of a raid if
they cheated
so if you're going for a raid race first
but i've just never heard of people
cheating in raids period
i guess that's true i mean i feel like
you just like nuke things faster if like
every sniper shot but i guess i don't
know
interesting yeah because i guess most of
the time you die to a white mechanic i
don't know if you usually
yeah cheat around that or maybe you can
get like somebody to rez
right after they i don't know i really
really don't understand why that doesn't
happen
i i just don't get cheaters man i don't
have that philosophy in my brain
i don't understand why you would do that
yeah but on a positive note they said
they are targeting an overhaul of trials
of osiris reward structure and
matchmaking paradigms to release before
the end of this year
again this is another one of those three
peaking season 15 trials before the end
of the year
this stuff is gonna be a while it does
seem like they have aspirations to
do some substantial things to pvp but it
does seem like
it hasn't when they said the renewed
focus for pvp
um they're taking their time to get
there it seems like it's
i wouldn't call it a focus not a hybrid
yeah i think it's a re-commitment to pvp
but i don't think it's a focus i don't
think pvp will ever be
in the spotlight of destiny and you know
what i think i'm one of the pvp players
who's actually like i'm okay with that
i think if i wanted to play a pvp game
where like the pvp sandbox was perfect
and
built around pvp i wouldn't be playing
destiny the reason i play destiny is
because it's attached to a larger
ecosystem
and a friend's group and there's other
stuff to do and the fact
the fact that pvp is as good as it is
when it's not the main focus
is part of the appeal it's like oh it's
one thing you can do in this larger
world
that's also really great um but
you know the it i i don't think that pvp
should be the main thing they focus on
that's crazy to me like that they would
even consider
like oh yeah pvp is like we're putting
all of our resources
and now you know the storyline is like
secondary like yeah that that that to me
doesn't seem like it'll ever happen like
they're probably gonna leave that to
call of duty in fortnight where
you know the pvp is is what they do and
then if there's
any story content it's sort of secondary
destiny is like the opposite of that
yeah i mean trials has been one of those
things that has
you know kept destiny afloat in some
pretty tough times especially in year in
destiny 1 trials was one of those things
on the weekends people would play
fairly consistently being is that was
about the only thing to do
so it is one of those pieces that has
continued between vault of glass
trials of osiris those have been a
couple feathers in their cap that have
given destiny longer legs than it
probably should have without them
and totally so i mean it's like it's a
piece that people still it like trial
still has a decent draw you see people
streamers come out to do that content
they get big turnouts and people want to
go through
and maybe some of this stuff will help
uh they do say
three points they want to work on
improve the overall health of the trials
matchmaking pool
both by incentivizing a wider audience
to engage
and better defining separation of skill
tiers i'd be
very curious how they do those
rebuilding the trial's reward structure
so that encourages more players to stick
to their objective or their active cards
longer
our current structure encourages a lot
of recycling cards after a single loss
meaning
the first games of your trials card has
a higher chance of being incredibly
challenging
yup that's why i don't play we want to
build a reward structure that
continually pushes higher skill players
to want to progress deeper into their
card even after a loss
making three and five wins more
achievable for more players
number three investigate opportunities
for solo players please
i read this one i was like you got
freelance and a couple other places
why not uh we believe this will not only
make the match making pools healthier
but also encourage more players to see
what trials is all about and hopefully
form social connections after
other pvp loving guardians lots of good
things in this one the first one is just
like
incentivizing a wider audience to engage
so i think that's good no notes
so where's the sub bullet point how you
going to do that yeah
yeah i mean i i have no idea how they're
going to do it but they say that that's
something they want to tackle
good that's that's been a problem ever
since the relaunch and season of the
chosen or worthy so yeah
uh the second one rebuild the trials
reward structure i think that's the
biggest thing i mean i've seen
yep cuj do his entire 30 minute video
about redoing trials
i mean the reward structure now is i
mean that's why i said it literally in
the middle of that sentence was
for me i had help to get my three win
card i got messenger a couple and then i
got help to go to a five but for me
right now you get z you get nothing for
a loss you theoretically go in there
with a bad team
and get nothing for hours and hours of
work and that no one wants to play that
there is zero benefit so your time is
not valued at all
that the and as i said how do you make
it engage to a wider audience
freelance would be one and they kind of
cover that in solo players
and then also the idea that whether high
skills should be rewarded
but low skills should not get nothing
and should it be able to grind for
some things now can you get a depth
weapon as a crap player
i don't think so i think the adept
should be something that's up there
for the chase but on the other side
not getting enough tokens for even one
random role that feels terrible too
yeah it does i i so i have a few
concerns about the three points they
made
on the the second point i really don't
like that that's correct they should fix
that
the first point i have a little bit of
concern about
um what they say about matching people
in skill
oh better defining separation of skill
tears
yeah that scares me um skill-based
matchmaking wasn't something that i
thought was healthy and i especially
don't think it's healthy in trials where
it seems like the metric they should be
using for matchmaking is ticket
status right the status of the ticket
how many losses how many wins that sort
of stuff
and the skill part of it makes me wonder
if
it's going to be technically easier for
people on
lower skill tiers to go to trials
because they're playing
lower stakes matches against people that
aren't as
good that that makes me a little
troubled and then for the third point
uh what was the third point again
just to investigate opportunities for
solo players so
the major max they're trying to make the
match making pools healthier
yeah so that one i also have a little
bit of concern about because
it's sort of like why we don't have
matchmaking for raids right because
you kind of can't do a raid unless
people are talking
yeah to me trials obviously you could do
it without
having a team communicate like i've even
done that before where we all just turn
off our mics and
then just play trials you know i've done
that before
but it's my problem with it is more that
it's not really in the spirit of what
trials is
trials is about like making call outs
and working as a team and kind of like
figuring out how to get to that higher
level
that higher playing level of like of
crucible
um and i feel like if you add it it
doesn't really it doesn't really force
people to do that
it also doesn't really force you to make
crucible friends
like i met a lot of great trials teams
just doing lfg
in trials and then meeting cool people
and being like hey let's do this next
week that was awesome that we went
flawless
and i i kind of will miss that if
there's just a method for people to go
in solo and so
it it's it's not that i'm afraid it's
gonna break trials i think if anything
adding the ability to play solo
will improve the player base which
ultimately is better for trials
i'm more worried about like what we lose
from trials
as part of destiny's culture i i worry
about that part of it more than anything
that said trials is so broken and not
fun right now
i'm willing for them to try anything
ignore all of my
ignore all of my complaints they are
minor compared to the fact that trials
needs to be addressed and like at this
point i'm not going to nitpick
on your decision making on this because
i know right now
can't be how it continues to be so like
do whatever like
ignore me completely as long as trials
get some
some love because i think it badly needs
it and and while i'm at it while i'm
while i'm complaining as i'm as i want
to do
uh stop canceling trials
like if something's broken just let it
be broken for a weekend it's not that
big of a deal
if i don't want to play trials because
something's broken i just won't play it
but if i do want to play it and it's
broken then we get to have another laser
tag weekend stop canceling it you know
just
let it just let it run its course that's
what i have to say
that's fair yeah just leave it leave it
in the game please like
i think you cancelled tried to rehash it
brought back the old after trying to
really rework it and then you just
reworked it into destiny 1 which was
hilarious
laser tag was fun um i never actually
thought about the whole
the spirit of trials because that's as
more of a casual pvp player i don't
think of pvp as much that way
so like you know the bonds you see the
teams that people play with they're like
weekly groups that you see people
running
i mean there are bonds when you have
like like going through an entire trials
card with the same person oh we got to
the lighthouse it was an awesome run
those are memorable moments especially
for some people's like first time or if
they get some consistent people to do
that over weekend
that's true now something like
in-game matchmaking for trials like mike
like however you like some way to do
like in-game
matchmaking on more of like a maybe a
solo match made
type thing where it's like have to have
mics on have to be able to
however something like that would be
nice to see a way to get people to try
it but have a way
you know in game i guess i know the lfg
sites i've used them too it's like i
would say
go use an lfg site because they're
beneficial i've met some really cool
people doing that it's how i had used to
do some old raids
but on the other side it would be nice
to see something i mean as you said
you could throw the entire playlist
trials up in the air and see what lands
and it can't be worse than it is right
now potentially because it's
in a bit of a struggle the skill piece
is
it's weird too because it knows like
because i come from the other side on
skill-based matchmaking
because i hear some people like oh i
just don't want to be sweaty all the
time i'm like okay so what you're saying
is
you want to stomp on the little you want
to have fun in some matches and by your
fun
it means stomp on the little guy and
they're like well i also want to have
you know i don't want to be like tense
every single match and it's like
i kind of get i get both sides but when
it is competitive to a point i feel like
skill should be
somewhat in there somebody said like
could you do skill-based matching
makings for
maybe the first few games to make sure
some people get a chance to be in low
levels
and then after you start getting there
kind of blended as you go like four five
six seven eight or however many and like
blend it into more of the card being a
focus the higher you get
so some people get into those first
three wins get a feel
that might help the solo players a
little bit as well get matched a little
better again it's like
they i would love to see they had
crucible labs at a point
they never used that they used it for a
couple random tests on
they used it for a couple eliminations
they used it for like a random showdown
thing and something else
there could just be some times where
like hey trials this you know for a
couple weeks we're gonna try
skill based matchmaking and one through
three four and five we're gonna fade
like less skill and card are gonna be
kind of balanced
and then when you get to the top three
that you gotta go for maybe those are
very heavily card weighted
some blend between the two that actually
isn't bad
i tuck said that in chat and i think
that could be one where you have
you know a bounce for both as you said
card being important in the top
especially for the lighthouse
that should be your you know seven to
seven duel potentially but in the bottom
i don't want to go against kami cakes
because that's not even going to be a
challenge
i think that's a good solution actually
i didn't think about that but i think i
think that is a good solution my
my concern and i'm not one of those guys
who wants to go up against people who
are super below my level
it's more that i don't want to
have the sweatiest games ever and then
have some team
just because there's a large pool of
people who
are in the lower tier of matchmaking
that they're getting to the lighthouse
and being like oh yeah we got there and
you know wasn't that hard didn't like
the whole point of trials is that if you
want to get to seven you have to get
better
you have to improve and like you should
be able to win three or four matches
because the pool is larger and it's a
lot of people who are trying to work
their way up the ladder but
you shouldn't be able to get to seven
just by
you know by keeping your current skill
level you should be forced to skill up
as part of the game mode like that's
part of the fun you don't
you don't feel good about winning a raid
if you if you clear it on your first try
you feel good because you wipe 20 times
and then you finally beat it and it's
like yeah i did it you know it's that
feeling of beating a dark soul's body
absolutely um and that's that's why
people like it
it's the same with trials you value a
trials win because when you get to the
lighthouse there's that big
lift off your chest you're just like oh
we got through it we beat them we got
better and then
it makes you want to play more um and
that's just another thing that
makes me worry about like the spirit of
trials and what it does
as like a community thing like that's
mostly what my
concern is when i think of like what we
want to fix in trials
i think people who say oh i don't want
to be sweaty over match i don't want to
like go up against the best people all
the time it's like
whatever you should have to face those
people during game six or seven anyway
yeah
you're gonna get there eventually yeah
if what you want is to stomp on players
who are worse than you then make a free
account and
do it on do it that way you know what i
mean like there's lots of ways to do it
but
no i mean trials is they want that to be
aspirational
and this like compared to a grandmaster
nightfall grand master nightfalls have a
lot of weight i have my issues with
grandmasters but that's for a whole
other podcast
um but they do want trials to be
aspirational because
they've set that as the pinnacle in pvp
to go after these adept weapons hence
grand master is kind of as the
counterpoint
and again it's the same piece of like
the time you put in but also
for pvp it's another thing like
ascendant nomad we had him on a little
while back and he did a good video about
how to revamp comp comp has been the
like redheaded stepchild of who gives a
damn what happens to this playlist
they did freelance in there which helps
for you know leveling up every season
which
isn't going to matter anymore so now
comp really has zero purpose again
so that's sad unless they make it a
pinnacle which i think they kind of have
to i think everything has to be a
pinnacle or what's the point
exactly yeah um and then what's the
point in pinnacles so then we're back
and it's just why is it called a
pinnacle yeah
doesn't make any sense weird um but like
the glory playlist would be another
thing that could get a lot of people to
get more into
into as you said trying to find that way
to
and that's why i think latter systems
would be good i played starcraft and i
was never that great at it but like
starcraft i think was one
where i played in the ladder system and
you're like i'm in gold too
and there's a chunk of players in my
group and i'm like okay i see the people
i'm gonna play up against this guy's a
little bit higher than me
i go against them okay they got me i
fell down a little bit i played oh i
beat this person i bumped up and you can
see that little progression that you go
through
because as you said i don't want to play
against people who are completely
terrible even against me i'm oh i'm okay
i'm like
probably literally a 1.0 kd just like
average dude
some people that i'm like yep i'm better
than you and there's a lot of people who
are better than me
i don't want to play against people who
are worse than me all the time because i
actually don't get better
when i played with like cami and mary's
and probably even like
playing with you and like high skilled
people i learn a lot doing that but also
if i play against
somebody who's too good i don't have a
chance to learn anything
there's no chance to be like well hey
this worked because we tried this and
hey this call out helped
if everything happened so fast between a
huge skill disparity
the person at the bottom doesn't get
much out of the match
so as you said there's some there's got
to be a balance to find a way to
have somebody for one they need
incentive to get into the playlist
whether it be comp or trials
and then from there find some way to
where they do like
get to learn but also don't get stepped
on and then as you said as well
but in the end like the card still needs
to challenge that's why that blend of
like the skill base actually isn't bad
but the incentive needs to be there for
all of it yeah i agree and i think the
comp playlist is a whole different
problem than trials like it's sort of
its own
issues but i agree i think a ladder
system would be the best solution and i
think
you get you should give people better
rewards the farther up the ladder they
are
so if they advance to the next ladder
then they get unlocked bonuses and then
maybe they get more xp
or whatever per match completion for for
continuing to play in and win matches in
that ladder
um and then it gives people incentive to
move up the ladder but if you're stuck
and you've kind of maxed out your skill
level you're kind of
you know you're in gold too you're not
going to be able to get any higher then
you at least get something that
silver 2 doesn't right because they
haven't gotten up to your level yet i
think that that
would be great for um comp for for
trials i don't think it matt
it it makes sense because you don't want
you don't want separate
skill levels for trials because the
whole point is that it's like survival
of the fittest
right yeah i mean that's the seven
that's the seven seven match exactly
there's exactly
there's gonna be a winner and loser on
those and that's kind of the point of
it's a weekend event it's not like a
season-long grind up and down the ladder
and seeing where you fall
but again it's like you've got to have
stuff in there and i wanted to ask you
just because i haven't probably asked
you too much
the adept mods are they
is the whole adept system worth it
working for you or not
oh yeah you're gonna hate my answer here
uh i have not played trials
i had uh i've not played it oh is that
true
no it yeah actually it is true i i
didn't play the first weekend
i wasn't high enough power i just i i
didn't level up enough
and then this past weekend wait has it
only happened one weekend so far
or is it happened twice we're on week
three so twice
yeah it's happened twice oh yeah in the
second weekend i was just busy yeah
messenger and then the crazy hand
cannons yeah we've had two weekends
that's right that's right the hand
cannon so yeah i've had two weekends
this weekend
i am 1300 power and i am free so i'm
going to be playing trials this weekend
and i will find out goodbye lady friends
yeah exactly but the last weekend was
her birthday and then the weekend before
that was i was not high enough power so
i just haven't gotten in there yeah i
said that on fire team chat and they
gave me a bunch of [ __ ] for it so
i'm gonna because they both did play
they but like paul tassie and brian were
both like yeah we did trials and i was
like
i haven't played it yet oh you idiot
so yeah i need to get in there but i'll
tell you i'm going to get adept weapons
this weekend just watch
so i was going to say though is that
enough of do you think those are good
enough rewards for the flawless chest
no no
i don't like those i was like for me
they're not incentive for me to go do a
grand master either
for sure oh no i would never do a
grandmaster strike dude those things are
at least my experience with that first
season when they introduced them i was
like this is
awful it's like hey do you want to get
killed by a scion in one shot
no well have fun yeah because that's
what this game mode is
yeah like i i hated that so um
yeah i don't think it's enough like i'm
actually i'm really weird and that i'm a
comp player but i
don't really care about perks that much
like i i obviously like god rolls and
that sort of stuff but i never
i almost never like seek out and like
grind for a god roll because
for me i'm like you know if it's a good
weapon and has good base stats i'll be
able to win the match with it like i'm
i'm not the type of guy who's like oh
well if it doesn't have outlaw on
rampage like how am i going to be
competitive and crucible like
i'm not super worried about that so um
yeah for me it's not enough i would
really like if there were unique mods or
something in there that you could only
get in that mode like in
trials and destiny one where you could
get primary weapons that had
uh an element like that's huge that's
like a game-changing event where it's
like all right i'm going flawless and
trials there's no way like i'm missing
out on that
i think they need some sort of big game
changer like that that makes people want
to jump into those modes because
there's just nothing there's nothing
unique there's
nothing you can only get there that that
changes the game in any major way that's
my problem with it
yeah i mean i'm with you and that's why
i was like in for grand masters i went
through and got conquer once mostly
because i got dragged
um i knew so two people who were willing
to take me through and then playing
through i kind of understood like
they had their strategies they had their
certain points but it is also
depending on the strike and depending on
what's going on like one of the ones we
did was
um it was the one that was on mercury
and it was the big round one with the
big hydra boss
100 cheese the crap out of that one um
yeah and it's like the
the idea with adept weapons whether it
be trials
the carrot needs to be worth the effort
now some people like ek has an entire
vault full of exotics that he's
masterwork because he's done he's
carried so many people through grand
master conquerors
he just is like rolling in exotics so
it's like cool you are
rare there are not a lot of you to
say like hey this is worthwhile but for
the average person if i'd be like ask my
brother do you want to do grandma no
do most people want to probably not
because the time
effort like the specific loadout that
you have to go through isn't worth it
same thing with trials
is the average person gonna see trials
as worth their time and effort to be
like
is their gun cool yeah it's not worth to
go flawless but if i can get the normal
gun down here
not the adept version is it gonna be
that much of a different for most people
no i got a messenger with outlaw and
desperado
i got one of the miracles on my four
drops i got the lucky one
now do i care about going after adept
100 could care
less like i got that enough and i got it
for a three win
it's fine that's cool that's how you get
some incentive for some people to get in
the playlist
but the flawless needs to be worth it
and that's where again i come back to
armor not being worth it either
like armor out of armor just needs a
rework so that's fine but i won't go too
far down that hole but that's the piece
is
like a depths on both sides just don't
feel like enough especially when some of
the adept mods have a give and take
none of those should have a give and
take at all they should only be better
to go through that much effort to give
you something that isn't
like just a benefit just kind of boggles
my mind a little bit
yeah i i agree i think um
you know what would be good to put in
trials you should be able to get like
a material that lets you masterwork an
exotic that doesn't have a catalyst
oh that would be worth it it doesn't
give you an extra perk it doesn't give
you like some
some new catalyst perk it just lets you
master work it so that you can
get generate orbs right on a on a on a
exotic that doesn't have a catalyst yet
at some point hopefully that isn't a
thing but there's still some of them
yeah
yeah there's there's a lot of them i
think and if they're going to continue
to release
uh weapons that don't have catalysts
then
maybe that could be something i don't
know my point is that there's lots of
there's lots of room to grow in destiny
and things that we don't have that we
should and it would be nice
what it what if trials and grand master
nightfalls
was the way that you were able to slot
equipment into your
uh your collections and pull it out yeah
i mean
that's what it was i was like you would
piss you would say a lot of people
have a lot of people but if that was the
way to do it like
everyone would be playing trials
everyone would be doing grand first
semester night falls if that was a thing
i'm just saying yeah with all the with
all the issues that there are in destiny
there's got to be one of them you could
solve by putting it behind an endgame
activity
that would make people become like
foaming at the mouth for it i mean even
what was it glass needles from destiny 1
re-rolling exotic stats
i have the exotic already well now i can
go farm them in lost sectors that's
basically doing the same thing
but i do have a phoenix cradle the brawl
just sucks
well if i go through and do a grand
master you can get this thing now some
people just sit there and farm a
thousand
and again they i feel and division had
the issue with this they don't need
they don't need to tailor completely to
casual but they also don't need to
tailor to like the 0.01 percent who have
like
just a vault full of supplies somewhere
in the middle you need to be like hey if
you actually go do this and you've got
an exotic
you can re-roll this and actually have
and maybe it's like
you could re-roll it and pick like i
want heistat in
at least one thing kind of like an
umbrella and you could do that like
stuff i'm with you
like this how about this imagine this
you fly into the lighthouse you've just
completed a seven
seven bit win trial weight has been
lifted off of your shoulder weight has
been lifted you're on you're on top of
the world
you come over the lighthouse right you
see the flames
and right there is this almost like a
in a super version of the prismatic
umbral recaster
where you get to design your own weapon
choose any weapon in the game
and you choose the perks on it and it
gives you the points so you can allocate
them on the stats the way that you want
put 18 and intellect you get to design
your god roll
for any weapon in the game once a week
every time you get to the lighthouse
just once a week so not farmable once a
week dude everyone
you can do it once that's your incentive
right there everyone's in that place
everyone's in that playlist casuals
doesn't matter
yeah it's just a design your own weapon
role
it's not game breaking it's not like you
can max out all the stats but it gives
you points to allocate and
and it lets you pick the perks out of
all of them in the game and you just get
to design your own role
once a week once a week you the only
thing about that you probably just got
to make sure you have enough weapons of
the game to do that
at a point and it could happen with
armor too you could do grandmaster
nightfall
yeah maybe that's how you get your armor
one yeah only thing about that with
weapons that don't go away
people would get an auto rifle a hand
cannon and then they'd be done after
about 12 weeks
that's true but that's why you introduce
new mods as you go and perks that
weren't in the game before and it's true
and you can
yeah you can do it this is so i think uh
i mean here's the thing though if you if
if you
now without with sunset go sun and sun
and going away
if you get the god roll that you want
one in a million
drop you get the gun with the perks that
you want and the stats that you want
you're in the same position anyway yeah
it's true i mean rng is just about you
just did it by luck
instead of by uh you know by doing it
through like trials or an endgame
activity so i'm saying
take away the luck let people design
their dream god roles but lock them
behind grand master nightfall and trials
in the most ridiculous way possible that
would be great
that's not horrible i mean that would
definitely get peop give you a reason to
do some of that stuff if grandmasters
were a little less just like
almost soul crushing and fakely it's
like it's artificial difficulty
said multiple ways but it's always just
like everything i'm gonna blink at you
wrong and you're gonna
i've just never liked that whole
difficult i'd rather see more mechanics
always than just like it's too hard now
you could have something be tanky
versus something that's just like i'm
gonna smash you and you can never get
better at this like
so anyway um
yeah i i know past personable yeah i was
like
i knew this was gonna be like a big
thing to unpack and crucible is like a
big one
i'm glad it had to be in here and i'm
glad it's
decently addressed but i will still will
say it's not fully addressed
because comp is still kind of undone
there's no mention of maps
i know trials is big but there's still
more to the crucible puzzle
that needs to be unpacked and kind of
explained and they've got more they said
coming this summer when it comes to
stuff that's coming next but crucible
it's a big one so we kind of had to talk
about it
uh the next one is paradise revenge so
in season 14 called that by the way
um vault of glass will return uh the
team will have a lot more to say about
it before launch but there are a few
things i'd like to clarify now
our philosophy behind bringing new
things out of the destiny content vault
is to keep them feeling like the content
you remember while updating them to meet
the destiny 2 difficulty and raid
standards
so while the high level experience
remains the same you should expect the
raid team to have a few tricks up their
sleeve
so it won't be exactly the same i'm
still curious how it's going to be in
the game
if you're going to have just that chunk
of venus for the opening section
i don't think they're going to have a
planet i don't think they can add a
whole planet
i think they did it with cosmodrome for
no reason just to add strikes
they're not going to finish the
cosmodrome and they're going to put
venus in the game
half of venus just like they do with the
cosmos i'm thinking it's literally just
like the patrol space in invisible walls
is all i think
like you won't have even like maybe
that's all i would guess
i think they're going to give us the
circle remember how every map in d1 was
just a circle
i think they'll give us like the circle
and then none of the
like caves and the strike areas go into
i think they'll do that because i think
they're gonna need
now that witch queen is delayed they're
going to need more strikes they're going
to need more content they're going to
add the
raid from venus so why not add the
strikes from venus 2 and then that helps
you pad your content for a while and
while you work on witch queen i i think
that's the route i think they'll add
venus
wow if they do that i count me surprised
so i will be curious to
refer back to this next season and see
what we get yes we will have to see
so i say i say venus is not coming to
that level
nor the strikes but that's just my guess
i would be
happily surprised and i would happily
like you know
buy you you know buy you dinner next
time i see you just if i'm wrong because
that'd be a much pleasant surprise
just the way their bandwidth seems to be
shown how limited they are
i don't expect it but i i agree and i
was really surprised when they pulled
back on adding the rest of the
cosmodrome because they said it was too
much work that made me go like oh wow
maybe they won't add venus but
um he did mention venus he mentions
venus in that post
yeah he says when you return to venus
did he mean
just just the vault of glass you're not
really going to the planet venus or was
that an allusion to the fact that
venus is coming back i i think the
latter i think they're
teasing at venus coming back as a planet
you can go to
yeah they said their tricks up your
sleeve when you tackle the depths of
venus
just have to see oh yeah that's a good
point depth of venus
like that sounds like the vault to me
but we'll see uh
multi-class will also launch with both a
contest mode
in the first 24 hours and a world first
race which i thought they said they
weren't going to do so i was kind of
surprised to read that
since this is a reprised raid we are
going to do worlds first
a bit different players looking to claim
the belt will not only have to complete
the raid
but also complete a curated list of
challenging triumphs
and while only one fire team will walk
away with the belt there are plenty of
opportunities for players to earn the
ability to purchase
some sweet real world loot through
bungee rewards so do you think like
on this one especially do you think
people are gonna have to do like
a flawless raid to be first no
i think it'll be the weekly challenges
that they add
as like triumphs except for they'll all
be active that week and
during challenge mode it'll be required
like if you fail the challenge it'll do
a team wipe
challenge failed oh that's what i think
it'll be so you might have two weekend
challenges
yeah we'll i think they'll all be active
okay at once
and then you'll just have to do them all
and if you get that challenge failed
it'll just do a team wipe
okay that's my theory that actually
probably makes the most sense i was
wondering if they were going to do like
you have to go through and beat the team
with entire ark subclasses or state like
those types of triumphs where you see
for like the seals
okay that would make a problem they'll
probably it's because people already
know the encounters so they have to add
something that you're figuring out so
they'll probably add challenges and
you'll be failing a challenge and not
know why
and then you'll figure out oh this is
how we do the challenge this is like the
new
twist that they put on it so i think
that'll be it because there was a hard
mode for vault of glass right
when they re-added it well it was like
26 and 30 were like normal and hard
first time through so there was some
escalation of mechanics
right because i think
king's fall was the first one of the
hard mode because i remember i was a
forever 29
so if there was a hard mode i wouldn't
be able to see it but you could go into
forever 29 it was because you could go
into vault right
because correct so then you i think that
but but was there two versions of it
what was the hard can you remember any
of the challenges i'm trying to remember
how that worked
um
oh were there like more yeah yes i'm not
so smart well you're right there was
more there was more uh gorgons in the
maze more
or less yeah different run more oracles
were there more or longer oracle run
maybe you're right there were more there
was a
longer oracle phase wow dude i
completely forgot about that
2014 crazy yeah they've done regular and
they've done hard
so then they're going to have like some
mix of like normal plus
hard challenges they're going to have
wyvern champions in
you know are you waiting for a wyvern
champion for sure for sure
yeah for sure if they don't add wyverns
that would be a huge
i would i would i think this would be
like
people would be pissed if they did this
but i think that they could even replace
that middle boss with a shield instead
of a hydra make it a wyvern
because that would make it more
threatening it's basically the same
encounter oh and then just it walks
around instead of just like walking
around
oh god that'd be terrifying because
that's because that's the worst thing
about that encounter is a lot of times
you're kind of just hiding from the boss
and waiting yep so if they made it a
wyvern they could like shoot at you and
jump around i think people would be like
wow this is a whole different encounter
that would be cool
it would need a couple of points i hate
why burns in the first place because you
can't ever find a weak point you have to
like
halfway kill him anyway before the weak
point shows up on both the front and
back but if you could like
put enough damage in team split kind of
on both sides
theoretically you could have two teams
like hitting both weak points
because they have i could see that
that'd be cool a 10 story wyvern
or who's actually here in chat remember
thick boy prothean or big boy
that's right yeah i want to see one that
big
yeah they can't change atheon because
it's so iconic yeah he's got a
boss i think the oracle boss i think
they i think they could make that a
wyvern without
people being too mad i'm probably
underestimating how mad the community is
cog would be mad he'd be like you're
ruining the spirit of vault of glass
yeah it is his number one raid so i
think hey if you want to play the
original vaulted glass you could play
destiny one bro
that's what i'm saying it's not like you
can't go and play well at the glass but
i played in a couple of weeks
yeah awesome and one last thing before
the end of the year we are looking to
add a
master version of vault of glass so
you're going to have
contest challenges master version of
vault of glass
we've been really excited about how
master and grand master difficulty
please look at grandmaster don't make it
wrong
an altered nightfall strikes increasing
the potency of combat and the importance
of executing mechanics
if they do this please fix overload
champions those suck the most
oh my god we're like you shoot them and
sometimes they don't get stunned and
then other times
their health still regenerates yeah i
hate that yeah overloads are the worst
barriers i can manage
and over uh unstoppable i can manage but
overloads are the most
like unreliable they're kind of broken
yeah yep
we'd like our future raid and dungeon
content offer
master difficulty versions where players
can earn adept raid and dungeon gear and
while we aren't able to commit to a
season 14 time frame for master vog
we do want to take the time to develop
and sustain a sustainable structure that
allows us to ship these closer together
in future releases
i mean the raid community is happy
they'll take they will be happy to have
a hard mode back
easily i think that's that's an easy win
now
and if you don't want to do it you just
don't have to play it yeah i'm just sad
they didn't mention vex smith the class
they're not going to give that secret
away until you have it in your hand
i want it that'll give a lot of people a
reason to go in there
if it's if it's fun we'll see uh
everybody's gonna need
gonna go in there they don't need a
reason there could be no rewards from
vaulted glass and people would still
play the crap out of it yeah oh people
do that for the nostalgia just be like
oh did you play this raid in destiny one
what was destiny one you gotta come in
here
like now uh in season 14
801 is returning to the tower from her
adventures i think she was out on europa
or something
and with her comes the ability for
players to take any armor they have in
their collections and turn it into a
universal ornament in destiny 2 we call
this transmog system
armor synthesis they can't just call it
transmog it's got to have a name
i thought that was funny every season
ada will awesome to be fair transmog is
a terrible term that nobody should have
put in any game i mean fair
transmogrification is
i don't even know who could speak armor
synthesis any better
that's debatable but transmog is bad so
just be like we have an appearance
screen now
period every season ada and this is
where i was curious how this mechanic's
gonna work because we were wondering for
a while every season ada will offer
players
a set of bounties that will highlight
various activity types
players can compete these quests and
receive the materials they need to power
up aydah's loom
apparently it's all cotton so we'll see
which can turn
any piece of armor in your collections
into a permanent universal ornament
so you're gonna have to earn every
single piece so i don't know how many
we're gonna get
players short on time will also be able
to purchase synthesis tokens for silver
once again and there's the grift yeah
you found it
there it is because there if you have to
earn every single piece you know
most people are going to be like if it
takes that long to get one piece yeah
all you have to do is
after you earn your first one you're
going to be like that was a lot of work
cha-ching go ahead and hit that cash
register
yeah once you've acquired some new
universal ornaments you'll want to head
over the new appearance screen in the
character menu where you can manage the
ornaments
on all your gear in one place you'll
find uh you'll find that even
you can even apply shaders individually
or all on one
all on one piece at or all pieces at one
time with one click i'm like
to make it even easier to try and punch
out new looks in season 14 we've also
changed shaders to be
permanent unlocks this took how long
meaning you no longer want to need to
hold onto stacks of shaders
so excited yeah you know a lot of people
are really
upset about the shader thing and i've
never cared like
i just don't want him in my inventory
that's all i just don't want to have to
it's just like an unnecessary thing
because what i can't remember was it
um what's the dawning
i swear every time you broke down a box
you're like shader shader shade or
shaders there's sometimes you just get
overwhelmed
and overall it's just like something in
my inventory i'll just turn in crucible
tokens or do things and all of a sudden
i'm full on shaders they're gonna have
to go breaks up it's just unnecessary
yeah the inventory part is annoying but
you know paul tasik cares about this
because he
spends a lot of time playing dress tony
and i'm i i play trash to me i i always
i'm with you this is the only beyond
light and i stuck with that set of armor
i was like all right i'm gonna make
one and i just kind of found a set of
armor kind of looked like ice
and i was like i stuck with that it's
the first time in probably a year i've
done that i'm with you i'm usually
i look like a homeless man dove into a
goodwill bin and
every colors on my body possible so yeah
that's my normal look
i love it that's such a that's such a
titan thing to do
yeah i love some of the twitter ones
where it's like how ugly can they make
the titan with like the old
um callus armor and stuff and you look
like crayons threw up on you yep
that's how big can you make those
shoulder plates how big
never big enough this season's
ornament's a prime example we got like a
zavala shield on that left shoulder
people were laughing until zavala
blocked that bullet with it i mean
yeah it's true pretty cool yeah they're
like we have to justify his shoulder
thing how do we do that let him block a
bullet
that's somewhere on a that somewhere
happened in a meeting i'm pretty sure
at the beginning of season 14 we'll be
including a new a starting supply of
synthesis materials as reward for
completing
the seasonal onboarding quest we know
many of you have been looking forward to
synthesis for a long time
and want to front load your ability to
create some looks you've been looking
forward to showing off i wonder how many
it's going to be
honestly think like 10 so you can maybe
do like two sets
is that almost too generous
well you're gonna be able to buy it so
they have to sort of uncap it otherwise
they'll be accused of
being predatory so i think they'll make
is
there'll be a way for you to earn as
many as you are willing to grind but
realistically no person is going to want
to grind for every armor set they have
so they'll probably just
they'll they'll they'll make a lot of
money off of this probably
more than they should but yeah it's it's
part of keeping keeping them
working they're doubling in size i was
like keep it coming
keep it coming wallet warriors we're
loving the
the results here we got got bungie
coming back
fiercer than ever yeah seriously 2.5
times the size of your uh headquarters
and
they're uh they're growing by leaps and
bounds finally we have combined fire
this is one thing you were excited of
how they're gonna manage it
cross play is coming to the masses in
season 15.
we'll be doing some internal rollouts
and alpha tests in season 14 to prepare
for the widespread launch
with cross play you'll be able to play
with all of your friends no matter what
platform
and don't worry matching console and pc
players and crucible
they're not going to do it unless you
specifically choose to invite console
players to pc
so and i won't no offense
no i mean a lot of a lot of my pc
players
like my clan are on pc so i will play
with them occasionally but
probably just i'll probably use
crossplay mostly for pve
like when i play pvp i'm just gonna
toggle that off
no thanks like i'll just play a console
so
i wonder how they're gonna separate that
like so if you wanna play
say you're on console and you have a
friend on pc if they join you are now
are you now in the pc space is that yes
okay
so basically basically they're they're
segmenting or segregating the player
bases
until you like willingly join across the
threshold basically
then you cross the threshold the other
one and it sounds like it's going to be
one way where
console players always cross into the pc
player base but pc players can't cross
into the console base and that's
probably as good as they can see
yeah yeah i think that's i think yeah uh
some of you noticed that icora ray has
not been around not only will you see
her again in season 14
she will be playing a pivotal role in
the witch queen oh and the witch queen
she don't die
she's going to be around at 14 and then
yeah so she's going to be around till
witch queen at least
so longer than i was kind of guessing
she gonna die
probably in which cognito's like if you
osiris doesn't have a ghost
if you're gonna kill off like horror
he's got no he's got nobody left
yeah i don't i don't know if they're
planning on killing off osiris
i could see him actually dying before i
quora because he's
i i mean he has no ghosts so he's
obviously primed for it but maybe he's
just a badass he's just thought about
that he does have all the supers
yeah he can use all the superstars he's
got saint
that's like golf he's like golly he can
use all the superheroes osiris has saint
14. so he just walks around with his
bible buddy
i was like oh yeah bubble shield them
bubble
uh in beyond light we introduced stace
to subclass like arc solar and void and
finally stasis will continue to evolve
into a fully supported damage type
in season 15 gonna take him nine months
to get there we will introduce our first
round of legendary stasis
energy and power weapons there will be a
lot more info here as we get closer to
fall
uh that also kind of tells you where
season 15 is going to fall season 15 is
going to be in the fall
which means season 14 is going to be a
long boy
these might be like six month seasons
well this is gonna end in may
so then you've got june july august
september
so that's four and then if you go
october november december january
four to five months probably per season
they're they're going to be pretty long
um but yeah actually getting
energy and power weapons of stasis now i
wanted to ask you
i feel like i've talked about this on at
some episode i don't know if you were
there
if they add stasis and they say they're
going to have more info do you want to
see stasis have a function
like freezing or do you just want to
like match the color
do you want to see them go into like
solar damage burning
uh arc damage like okay yeah me too
i think i think solar damage should do
damage over time as people catch on fire
i think arc damage if you do enough of
it it should
make somebody have a static that spreads
to other targets
i think that uh freeze should slow you
down and eventually freeze you if you
take enough damage
and void should also do something yeah
what's the one i can never decide i
picture like gravity well is what i
always go to
but i always wonder what void could do
because we have damage over time from
fire
and i still think witch queen is gonna
have like a poison i'm still picturing
that as like a toxic or like a decay
there will be other there will be other
darkness subclasses but i don't think
it's bad if like
two of them are damaged over time and
one's fire and one's poison i don't
think that's the end of the world there
should just be
some consequences of shooting someone
with one element over another that's my
whole point
i think uh slow i don't think it would
work i don't think we're gonna we can't
maybe sorry for void oh there you go
weekend yeah we can
make them make them more susceptible to
other types of damage yeah
i think that they should make all of the
elements
have an effect and also interact with
each other in different ways
like i think that if somebody is uh you
know voided
they should maybe are more susceptible
to fire or if they're you got the rock
paper scissors lizard spock thing going
on yeah
there should be some sort of interplay i
don't i i think uh
it's i'm like 99 sure that's not gonna
happen
i think they're just gonna add uh the
stasis element on weapons and then
they're gonna add it as a shield on
enemies and
the reason that's bad is because it only
hurts us it means that now we have four
elements we have to worry about we only
get three weapons only two of them
get to have elements so it means we're
never going to be able to use them for
all
which means that bungie has to think
about which shields they put
into strikes and into raids be if
especially if we can't change weapons
um it makes everything more complicated
and i really hope that they
i hope i'm wrong i hope i'm wrong and i
hope they they
are thinking more about hey why are
elements in the game like why did we put
these in here do they should they have
some sort of effect and
should destasis present like a larger
question
for the sandbox i'm with you because i
think that hopefully leans
them more and more into that rpg that i
think a lot of us would like like me i
would like you know armor to have
i mean even for me mobility doesn't make
you run faster that still just blows my
mind
that yeah that doesn't bring us up every
episode
but that's as you said like also you
picture okay so i have a fire weapon
what does it do
it matches the color well what about
this blue one you're just playing match
the color at this point
somebody on a podcast said that before
and i was like it so simplifies it but
that's really all you're doing
it is it's like the mass effect 3 ending
it's it's
it's all color and no actual
consequences oh [ __ ] you haven't played
mass effect true
i've heard i've heard about the chaos of
that but the reason you've heard about
the chaos of the end
but it's like yeah the remaster is none
of the actual
yeah and then i also think like uh in
terms of
us taking damage like we take damage
from stasis
sources and we start to get slowed in pb
pve
i think you know and also we need to
burn damage
we take burn damage too like i don't
know why we
take chris thorne
does its poison damage or something
right we have all these debuffs
but we can't do them dads so like the
effects are almost in the game it seems
like it is as now that you say that
it's halfway there incoming just needs
to be outgoing
yeah and we also it would give it would
give armor more options if you could get
armor that
negated the effects of solar damage so
you couldn't catch on fire
or negated the effects of stasis so that
you couldn't freeze
uh stuff like that that's like oh you
know i've
you've got your stasis ability well i've
got my helmet that means i can't get
frozen by stasis stuff like that like
that would be
awesome because then it's another game
of and maybe if you have a piece of
equipment equipped that
makes it so you can't catch on fire it
makes you more vulnerable to stasis and
you can get frozen easier stuff like
that where
you're kind of making um rpg like
exactly uh very very consequential
decisions with
the armor you choose and the weapons you
choose and the sandboxes
is ever evolving it would be so awesome
well i mean right now even on your arm
your chest piece you have arc solar and
void damage resistance
we don't have a stasis resist can you
imagine if there was like a chest mod
that was just like stasis resistance and
the effects of stasis are like
25 percent less you're harder to slow
like one more all that stuff is just a
little bit longer
everybody would be wearing that thing in
pvp or maybe that's why it's not in the
game
but like or just just give me an exotic
chess piece called crucible is now
playable
where you don't get frozen by stasis you
can you can be slowed
you still have some yeah that would that
would be a thing
they also took apparently everybody's
recommendation that gilded titles now
have a little
square root on the end so you'll have
your
your little pip shown i'm gonna feel
really sad that i'm never gonna get
any of those because i like for me doing
going out of my way to complete triumphs
that i wouldn't achieve organically is
like not my idea of fun and destiny and
i almost never do it
like you're not that great i did it once
you can see my
my pins back here all the ones i earned
yeah and
and like i i like went out of my way i
was like all right i'm just gonna suck
it up and do it because i only have to
do it once and now that there's the two
and three being added i'm like
no because that means everyone's gonna
know i only did it once and i'm gonna
feel inferior when somebody has like
you know unbroken four and i only
bothered to go out of my way to get it
once but
yeah it's just the i like it i think
it's good it shows off the
the achievement for people who are
really really into destiny i'm just
going to feel
inadequate flawless 12 you don't have a
life
yeah exactly you're also showing 12 how
much time you spend
yeah that's true that's true uh then
finally say they can't overstate how
excited i am for what the team has
planned for the year and beyond
and they show the picture of the armor
set i was curious what you thought of
this like
witch queen armor thing going on and
some people are already speculating
about this like
worm tentacle spiral thing that's going
on
it looks like uh aerosmorn cosplay
kind of does actually i like it's it's
got the hive thematic but also
yeah it's like a hive blended with like
military it's weird for like the titan
at least with the
you know it's concept armor so i'm
trying not to judge it but my first
thought was meh i wasn't like oh
like you know blown away but i i mean
i'll wait till it's in the game i'm sure
i'm gonna want it
it looks like it definitely stands out i
will give it that it seems unique
and that's a hard thing for them too
they got to keep coming up with armor
sets and
i will give bungie a decent job that
they continue to make sets that stand
typically apart from other things like
this looks that's true
like its own kind of piece they always
have weird accessories and stuff like
that on there that's kind of funny
um but that is the giant thing that is
uh the state of destiny 2 we also had
the twab
so obviously it rehashed the state of
destiny 2021 we also have the master
version of dead man's tail for presage
am i saying that right now pressed your
pres no idea
but i can't remember i looked it up and
i was like how do you pronounce it it's
like
presage or presage i think it's
literally pronounced both if you google
it i can't remember it's not pre-sage
i know that it's not pre-sage not
pre-sale yeah
um and that one is timed i was actually
kind of curious your thoughts on that
one because i tried it
and i got to the hanger and i ran out of
time
but if it wasn't timed i know i could
finish it so it's kind of curious if you
like the time or if you don't
um i i actually didn't mind it um i
i remember not liking timing so much in
nightfall activities for some reason i
think maybe because i perceived them as
being a little bit more casual
um but in in this it's like a one-time
activity it reminds me of whisper of the
worms
uh heroic mode where where it was also
timed um and i i was able to beat it we
i think we beat it on our second track
whisper but yeah it's like this one i
guess this one is more back to the power
level grind
eventually i'll be able to yes but right
now so
it like i jumped i can't do enough
damage it's just not fast enough yeah
so the first time i tried it i did it
with some people i play with on xbox and
i was
uh 1980 i think was my power level so i
just
got obliterated oh man um but then or
what is it what's the current power
level right now uh 13
10 is the power cap so yeah sorry
i was 1280 and then i i leveled up to
13. and
uh went into it and it was not not that
hard at all so we
i think we did it with several minutes
left um so yeah it is
it is a power level grind which again
this like makes me wonder like
why is there a power level grind yeah if
you if you had a normal
like a normalized level and i went in as
a solo player
it's going to take a lot of coordination
for me to have my stuff together
but in theory just because i haven't put
like
you know my artifacts not plus 20 and i
haven't rated every week
yeah i'm 13 11 or 13 12.
which isn't bad yeah but i'm also not
esoteric who was 13 26 and did it in the
first hour
yeah exactly i was like he's a beast so
it's fine but like
i was wondering his level it's like 1326
i'm like damn that's high already
people people complain about time gating
to me
putting arbitrary power caps is like
free time gating
something no i mean that's legit like i
want to play how much free time do you
have
yeah so that's why the leveling kind of
bugs me too because if it was just like
if it had a few more mechanics or there
was a different route through it and it
wasn't just
here it is higher level than it was
before and everything's the same it's
like well i could go do it
i can solo it normally right now it's
literally just i can't do it fast enough
because
whether i'm alive or not i can't put
enough damage into the guys that's
literally all it is and i was just like
it kind of bummed me out a little bit
because i really enjoyed the mission
like the horror aspect last week i was
talking to cognate it was just
they did a really cool job with the
ambiance and like the sound design in
there when i walked in and the big
rumble of the first time in the growl
was like
all right audio team you killed it you
did awesome and then it's like a go to
mac
halo reference the star wars reference
the star wars one i knew you lost your
mind i was like where is travis right
now
oh i was literally shouting 3po the
whole time i was like 3pm
as i was running around looking for a
way out oh
that one was i was sliding down i was
like what's down here
and then we slide down and i was like
what are these oh crap and then as soon
as it starts here like all
like totally nailed the star wars piece
and then i'm like trying to jump around
on the floor
they did really good but yeah just it
kind of the halo thing i caught
immediately too
yeah okay i saw that on twitter sorry
have you not played halo i haven't
played that much i've played it off and
on a little bit but i don't have like
this like i know
i just broke travis you did just
like yeah it's it's a it's like a
reference to
combat evolved i think it's it's like
pretty obvious when you walk in it's
like that's
that's the bungee like hanger yeah
it's yeah anyway yeah i saw that roaming
around on twitter and somebody's like oh
i knew it the first time i walked in i
was like
sadly i did not at some point i should
play those at like 4k
if i ever get my 4k monitor there's a
lot of games that i want to make look
pretty i'm almost there
i'll i'll run halo with you man i need
to play all of the halo games before
infinite comes out anyway
so yeah that would actually be a good
time whenever halo is coming out to go
through the story to kind of catch up
because i am this far beyond off on what
that story has
start to finish so that would be good
actually great somebody like
somehow i got gifted the collection too
so i have it now i need to play it
well i will play it with you with
director's commentary
you're the director yeah i'm the
director i will take your director's
commentary because it'll be like
your um who's the director of fast and
furious some of the recent ones less
something lin
uh justin justin lin yeah hey i had the
last
genius you did i'm i'm pretty um i was
like i was gonna say jason lynn and i'm
like that's not right but
um i was like i don't even need him when
i watch those movies i just need you and
discord and be like
i'm like i'm currently one hour and okay
so right now what we've got
[Laughter]
is zach giving me the commentary i found
out you i found
i found it in my neighborhood because
movie theaters aren't really a thing
right now
that they're renting out individual
movie theaters for one hundred dollars
you can just
go and you can just go and see a movie
in a movie theater by yourself
so i'm gonna do that for fast and
furious nine when it comes out because
it's finally coming out in may i'm not
gonna buy a movie theater and just go by
myself i kind of want to do no friends
if i could if it's a decent i thought
about for tenant last year doing it for
like my wife and i because i like
christopher nolan movies though
it was really interesting and this one
was definitely a mind mess you up
um but yeah same thing here i've thought
like if a big enough movie came out like
i have about six friends like our group
of six like if we could do that and
split it that's a no-brainer like
what is that 33 bucks a couple no
problem it's cheaper
it's cheaper than buying tickets back
before cove yeah
so well especially for you in california
god theaters out there not cheap so
yeah it's like 15 bucks a seat yeah um
they're they do some deep stone [ __ ]
deep dive i didn't read through all oh
it's going to be the raid along
so wednesday march 3rd they're going to
do a raid along for the deep stone crypt
deep side those are always awesome to
see like
they'll show like concept art and this
mechanic and encounter used to work this
way so those are always really cool so
if you guys don't catch it live
it'll be 10 a.m pacific wednesday march
3rd they're gonna be going deep into
that one
which also means that week is probably
pretty quiet for destiny which is good
um but those are just always cool so if
you're curious if you enjoy that raid
i'm very curious how they explain tanix
because they have to explain why he is
in the end of that raid because he just
doesn't fit
he's just like the guy bolted onto the
ship in the end so i'll be curious what
they talk about right
uh they do talk about ritual weapons so
ritual playlist weapons
said to be at the beginning of beyond
light we introduced new weapons into the
roared pools of crucible gambit and
vanguard strikes to give a quick rundown
of the new lights
out there each of these weapons has a
low drop rate and deep perk pools
intended to give players dedicated
so this is an example of bottom dollar
and gambit
i was kind of curious what you think
about
like going after one of those because
they are
next to impossible to get the one you
want but it has also increased the
people playing gambit so i was kind of
curious if you
yeah like it don't like it i'm i'm i'm a
fan of anything that
gets people to actually concentrate on
activities i think it's crazy that right
now there's like no direction it's sort
of just like
do whatever you want and maybe you'll
get some rewards but probably
you won't and like i think that they
should
like i think the bottom dollar thing is
cool it's actually giving people a
reason to play gambit
unfortunately if you don't like gambit
you have a bit of a problem and that's
kind of in my in my opinion that's like
a separate issue it's the fact that
gambit just isn't fun and they haven't
really put any love or attention to it
same with crucible in some regard but i
like it i think that's cool
um would i prefer if there was a way to
get it guaranteed drop without having to
grind gambit for 20 hours
absolutely again i would like to refer
you to my
idea for trials where if you go flawless
you get to design your own weapon and
pull it from any pool in the game
i think that's a great idea and it could
you know put some time into this
activity you get five gambit wins in a
row
and you can pull the slot machine six
you can pick this perk
seven then you're just gonna have people
like cheesing bosses and stuff that they
already do but that's a whole different
thing
no i don't mean it for a gambit i mean
like four trials you should just be able
to pull it from anything oh anyway so
you bill i want to buy a dollar out of
trials period
exactly yeah exactly so give those more
because they're
in my opinion there should always be a
way to get a guaranteed drop like i
i really detest the fact that i've had
to do the raid every single week
to get eyes of tomorrow and i still
don't have it yeah like i to me the gold
standard was
um um what was the
last uh yearly release
first no not for a second um how am i
getting this name
uh the moon one shadow key was that
expansion called shadow keeper thank you
i was like which one have we talked
about no no you're good
to me to me the gold sander was shadow
keep where uh
during the raid divinity you got by just
doing a hard
version of the raid where there's a
challenge at the end right like or a
challenge throughout yeah like to me
to me there should be like a a way to
get it
but the way is hard or you can just get
it by doing pure luck
uh and just doing the rate of a week
there should be multiple options but i
i'm a fan of them
providing like a a hard mode where if
you beat it it's guaranteed because
um ain't nobody got time for that yeah i
mean that's
played world of warcraft to bring it up
too much but there were very very like
specific weapons for say like a hunter
class or a druid or whatever it was
and there was like a legendary quest and
there was always one for a hunter and i
ended up doing it for other people which
was always funny
but you had to go out in the world and
there were like four bosses you had to
like find
spread out everywhere if you beat those
four you could put these pieces together
and get one thing out of the raid paired
with doing all this quest you could do
it like
there's a long drawn out way and it was
not easy to do but as you said it's a
way that you can
with a lot of skill effort and you know
persistence you can get it as opposed to
i can be as persistent as i want it just
won't drop
there needs to be about like you can get
lucky or if you just want to go grind
that thing out you weren't unlucky that
first week you got a lot of skill
go nail it just go hammer this thing out
also i just want to bring up on this
podcast that
bungie claims that eyes of tomorrow has
a
increasing chance of dropping and i
think they're liars
it seems like a lot of people are
starting to question that because
i don't think that that's true i i fully
doubt it
um and yeah if i'd love to be proven
wrong but
show us the show us the numbers bungie
that's what i said i mean i've seen
people in the 40s and if that's true
it seems that's too high
like what do you think is a fair number
how many times do you think you should
have to run a raid before you're like
you're guaranteed exotic 10 20 15 five
what i think you should have to run it
one time on a harder mode
or you know 30 times on like its normal
setting
thirties like i already have gotten it
for doing i beat it on contest
yeah i think the content like why didn't
i get it no i beat it on content so that
brings back to another thing contests
should be available for on any raid
yeah and if you do it on contest you
work through you figure out the
mechanics
doesn't matter how high you are in level
still of the mechanics if you can do it
on that
i think you should be guaranteed that
that'd be a nice way to do it what if it
was the only way to get it that's how
they should do it
if it's the only way to do it i think
then you're gating some people behind
skill which despite being a crucible
person i'm
i'm actually not a fan of i think uh you
should be as inviting as possible with
pve content but
i think there should it should be either
or like either you do it
you know 20 times uh on the normal mode
and you eventually just get it by luck
or you just do it once on a mode that's
spectacularly hard and and you brute
force it but like
as somebody who beat it in the first 24
hours i'm like come on all right yeah i
mean
you're dude you're due by now for sure
yeah biggest thing about those weapons
though they said they are going to
they don't want the drop rate to be high
so it's not a short-term grind
they said as they get towards later in
season of the chosen they're gonna like
increase the drop chances for the ritual
specific weapons i guess to give you
more roles throughout the season
and i guess that works but that also
means do you grind it out early
or do you wait two months and just grind
it hard later and have more chances
stuff's always kind of weird like it is
it's one of those things they do a lot
at the start of this thing you're gonna
get less drops but later on you're gonna
get more of
fill in the blank they do that for a lot
of things whether it be
oh yeah they do whether it be the
community things oh you guys are going
to be too slow here's 10 times of that
oh the drop rates are too low and you
guys are complaining we'll give you a
little more late like
it's always start really tight okay
we'll loosen the reins a little bit
happens they do that all the time
they do yeah um i think that's most of
it though there's a lot of cool art
always in there
um so another 12. what about beefy week
this turned out to be it was two and a
half hours between two people
i was like i was gonna say as for like
what we have
obviously state of the games the big one
um
any major p like what at this point
where does he where how where's your
excitement at are you looking forward to
season 14 with transmog
season what is it like
witch queen 15 or 16 for the witch queen
yeah 16 is which queen
15 is some stuff's coming in 15.
like where where's your next big how far
ahead are you looking
i'm looking all the way man i think my
excitement is even for like
the end of the light and dark saga and
it's for what's happening beyond it
my my excitement is more like like i
don't really care that much about what
happens in season 14 and 15 to be honest
like
obviously i'm gonna play on my host fire
team chat i'm going to talk about it
every week
um but i don't expect a ton to happen
and my
the majority of my excitement isn't
rooted in like the stuff that's coming
right around the corner it's in the
stuff that's
the witch queen and farther like witch
queen is obviously the next big one i'm
excited about because clearly they're
taking the time they're delaying it they
want to make it good which
really excites me but i'm just excited
about like destiny has a future and it's
going to be a long one and it's going to
be a bright one and the team is
doubling in its size and like how could
that not make you excited if you care
about this game
and i would say like if you have ever
played destiny
destiny 1 or destiny 2 you should read
the state of the game that came out this
week
and just like think about getting back
into it because like
i think a lot of people assume that with
some of the missteps that have happened
over the years that
maybe destiny would continue to be an
alright game and maybe it would kind of
extinguish and i think a lot of people
thought in recent years with them
announcing
three years in a row and the last one
called lightfall that maybe they were
planning on ending it
and we could not have been more wrong
yeah like facebook is here to stay
and they're doubling down and bungie as
a studio is going to be making more than
just one game they're going to be
i think the next activision they're
gonna be like a big studio with lots of
games under their belt
um and yeah i could not be more excited
for destiny's future and just knowing
that it has a future and just seeing
that the passion is still there
and the team still wants to make this
game they're not like over it like they
were with halo i just want to move on to
the next project right they want
they want to stick around and develop
this world and that just it fills me
with so much
uh joy and excitement and also makes me
feel a little vindicated because a lot
of my friends thought that
destiny wouldn't be around forever i
always played it i always played it from
the very beginning back when we were
running around the cosmodrome and
grabbing spin metal on my friends
spin metal farming loops yeah dude i
remember people making fun of me for
that why are you playing this game and
now i just get to look at him like
man he should have stuck with it got
that new destiny movie coming out next
week you know
got uh destiny 8 on the horizon i'm very
excited to
play that yeah um that's kind of where
i'm at too because yours is like
the story is as i said what has to be
intrigued because they have this
for one they have a light and dark saga
that has three plot three and a half
years to go
that whole thing has to get finished
means biff has at least done three and a
half years of lore and then more
obviously
um but also it seems like i'm with you
like which queen is where my eyes are
looking over 14 and 15 because they're
the stepping stones to these big systems
they're working on
do how deep do they go into the rpg what
are they gonna do with the armor
um all of like an armor 3.0 feels like
it's got to come
because transmog really makes armor
useless and they've mentioned it already
so something is working with armor which
is
half my loot so i'm excited but that
also means i don't care about armor and
tilden which is kind of sad
um and i think between now and then like
the activities will be like
there's probably going to be an exotic
quest here here's your exotic with the
season pass
um here's some mods here's your you know
match made activity maybe at least they
seem to be getting a little closer like
that stuff's going to be in each season
and but those are going to be longer
we're going to have some down time and
it's not a bad thing to have some
downtime away from destiny i'll be
curious how they spaced those things
but for me i mean if you think like
horizon forbidden west and we just went
through the state pla the state of play
for playstation
there's at least something once a month
that i want to play and it feels like
i'm going to have more time to
bounce back and forth and do that some
people like i have to have like destiny
all the time
gonna have to have a little more space
in there but i'm with you witch queen
lightfall
beyond the next saga like
i don't even i don't know how far they
take it
but i am very i would love to be a fly
on the wall to know
what is what that plan is because we
just got an expansion we didn't know
existed now we're like
we have three and a half years of
destiny guaranteed
period like that's i never expected to
read that today i will say
which is cool it's great um and then for
you on the other side
trials is just fantastic so getting
hopefully they'll get some of that stuff
worked on too
um but i've probably kept you for long
enough it's been
an awesome chat though happy to do it
man i always love hanging out with you
um yeah i know we'll get we'll get you
back on sometime soon when cog's here so
we can get a good chat but
uh yeah all of those of you guys who are
curious about the workout in chat uh
since i'm wearing this shirt
uh we're not working out today in chat
so i turned those points off
so make sure nobody especially since
he's also not wearing pants
i'm wearing shorts i'm just not wearing
like suit pants
he's commando below the belt yeah
there's nothing below this shirt you
guys don't want to see that
i just took my pants no i'm just kidding
um
quick rundown though top three fast and
furious movies
oh uh fast five is number one for me
uh number two would be the original the
fast and the furious
and number three would be furious seven
paul walker's last yes okay yeah yeah
those are solid
um i think i'm not like i've thought
about this or no
not at all five is definitely when i
would say the franchise was
like the turn i never expected of that
being a highest movie and then being so
like fun and well done nailed it yeah uh
the og started it all i agree
uh seven was good the way they handled
paul walker was surprisingly like i
cried in the end of that and i'm like
what am i doing crying in a fast and
furious movie but totally did
yeah um i cry everything and then i have
a weird sweet spot for tokyo drift
tokyo drift so i love all the fast and
furious movies equally and i say that
even though it's not true
um but fast and furious tokyo drift is
close to my heart just because justin
lin i think is like
he's the reason fast and furious is so
great he's a genius
like i could talk forever about like why
i think that that guy is just like
a master storyteller but yeah i really
like tokyo drift and the main character
also reminds me of you
i don't have that much of a southern
accent there
little yeah i know but he's from texas
he's oh yeah he's that guy
for sure but yeah yeah he looks like you
it was like i watched that and i was
like i know it's got some cheesy lines
and things but i was like
you know there's a good little underdog
and like the mustang drifting i was like
it's so kind of ridiculous but i was it
was like one of those that i watched and
i'm like
two okay what's your least like because
mine's probably
too fast if you're into two yeah the
worst then i think four is just above
that one
four i would put a long way above
too fast too furious i think too fast
too furious is like without a doubt
first one like yeah i mean like five six
seven
eight kind of built eight is like
eight's a bit crazy
um six i like eight yeah i don't i don't
have a problem with it just because i
i think dom is amazing and i love it
every time they go even more crazy yeah
and
i'm like we're going to space we're
going to space right that's what they
say
that's what they say i mean i think uh i
i
i have a theory or i have a suggestion
for the final fast and furious movie
which is going to be fast 10 it's a
two-part they're doing like the harry
potter thing
i think it should be a time travel movie
where they have to go through all of the
previous fast and furious
timelines oh this is going to be amazing
yeah and it'll be called
um the past of the furious and
uh the catchphrase will be fast 10 your
feet seat belts
why are you not on their marketing team
i mean i don't know and
it writes i've already thought of this
it literally writes itself
actually i think yours is 11 the sequel
nobody wanted with a different cast
that's right well they're gonna they're
already setting it up so a lot of people
don't know this but
fast and furious has an animated series
that's on netflix
and it's about dom's uh nephew who's
like a kid and they
go and get in the car shenanigans so i
think what'll happen is after 10
comes out both parts of the movie i
think they'll get rid of the old cast
and then they'll do like a young
like reboot where it's like maybe people
related to paul paul walker's character
brian has a kid yeah he's already in the
show now then diesel's character has a
kid that's in the the movie so i think
they're setting up like the next
generation the teen titans fast and
furious
that's right i think that's where it'll
go and it will get there pretty quickly
well you know and then we'll have like
vin diesel like old with a beard making
a cameo please don't
just a cue ball and a beard just doesn't
seem right
yeah well he'll be like marcus from uh
from gears of war they'll give him like
a
you know do rag so you can't see uh his
his balding
his probably ball the deadline yeah yeah
still gotta have like the t-shirt and
the arms that don't fit it so that's
just how that goes that's right yeah
that's right
well man it has been an absolute blast
thank you for sharing plenty of time
with me to talk about what was a crazy
episode um we will definitely have to
find a time to get you back
on sometime soon we can spend with you
me and cog
um we'll make that one work and then
other than that man
uh tell people what you like for what i
wanted to shout you out great job on
fire team chat recently by the way i
know you've been hosting it
been enjoying the shows you got paul
over there and brian of course um
i just wanted to say like you basically
picked up and
i mean destin's been running that thing
for a while he is i loving the cameos
you guys are throwing in with him
reading to his kid and stuff has been
great so i just wanted to shout you guys
out
for kind of just the smooth transition
and just how you guys have made that
continue to work
and then i wanted to ask you like for
for you how's it been hosting that one
did you feel any pressure has it been
like
looking at the comments and seeing are
you just like i'm doing a podcast have
fun or not
yeah um i i'm one of those people who
um destin i don't know have if you've
ever had a chance to meet dustin or talk
to him or whatever
very little like pretty minimal but a
little bit he's he's like one of those
guys who like outwardly he seems really
like hard but he actually is one of
those people who
lets comments affect him which you
wouldn't expect just meeting destin like
he reads comments and he like takes them
to heart and
lets himself get affected by them and so
before i started doing shows or having
like a public face i assumed i would be
like that
and it turns out i'm not like that at
all
i get comments and somebody will call me
like a racial slur
or like say that i'm like the worst
thing in the world and i just look at
and i just go
and i move on it doesn't ruin my day at
all so i mean that's the best attitude
for sure
i yeah i i don't let it affect me
personally that said i do
feel an enormous sense of responsibility
with fire team chat like i was a
listener years before i ever got on the
show and
i knew the cast because i worked with
them for years at ign before
i was you know writing for ign and so
for me like
you know it's it's really bizarre being
on the show it's even more bizarre
hosting it like a year after my first
episode
um but destin built something that's
awesome and i think a lot of
shows about destiny or the fact that a
show can exist about a single game on
the internet i think
is something that destino's a lot of
credit for he kind of like
he certainly proved it with like ign
because ign doesn't do that right they
don't have shows oh yeah
about a single video game um and and i
think that
he's out a lot of credit for that and i
love the destiny community and and
so for me i'm trying to figure out how
to how to be better how to
keep the show as it is but do my own
thing you'd notice i added like the
bungie please segment
i'm doing the uh the cold open skits
which i really like and i want to keep
that going even after dustin's back
and and uh you know i want to i want to
see how we can make it more fun and
change it but but keep it
the same three-person show that that
happens and
uh now doing it every other week i think
makes more sense it feels a little
counter-intuitive right now because
there's so much going on in destiny but
i think in a few weeks when things start
to cool down and the seasons are longer
us doing every other week is gonna feel
like
like it makes a lot more sense um so
uh yeah and it also just gives us a
chance to do longer episodes and to work
on them more so i think that's the the
plan going forward but
yeah man i'm not letting any of the
criticism really get to me but i am
taking constructive criticism seriously
trying to make the shows
good as it can be and and you know
feeling the enormous weight of
such a show that's special to me even if
other people don't watch it like to me
it's like the destiny show the one that
i always listen to and so uh yeah i'm
just
i'm i'm very uh humbled by it and
excited i'm just having a lot of fun
hanging out with paul and brian every
week and
those guys are hilarious like you got a
good crew um
and just yeah props to you guys the
longer ones with the
the like and as you said that's perfect
it's like the every other week
especially as we now things are going to
be delayed we'll have some slower times
it's going to be perfect some will be
busier some won't be but the
length lets you guys i feel like
sometimes and again i don't know what
ign
does and you obviously don't you don't
have to disclose anything there are
times where i feel like there are
certain times constraints you're
supposed to hit
for whatever metrics or ads or whatever
you guys are supposed to do
and you know you guys having a little
more time to talk just feels like
it gets to breathe a little bit some
people i know like shorter but it was
like just a little bit more because i
think this last one was like close to an
hour or so
might have been a little over more than
yeah like it was almost 90 minutes yeah
yeah and those are where and that's i
guess
coming from our podcast i'm biased we're
way too long but
uh i enjoy when you get to go have some
tangents some deep dives and you get
some thoughts that kind of fall out of
your head
that probably wouldn't if you were on
just such a tight one so
it's it's nice to see it's just nice wit
for anybody i think
podcasts generally get to have a little
bit more freedom and
just realism to them when they get a
little bit more room to breathe and i've
just i've enjoyed that so
overall yeah you guys are doing great
enjoying the cold opens and the bungee
please
like it's good to evolve
and yet uh appreciate what you got
awesome thanks man
yeah um well if you want to let people
know i think i got a thunderstorm
outside so hopefully i don't lose power
um yeah if for some reason shuts off you
guys know why
uh let them know where they can find you
um when you guys got your next one i
think and
just where yeah what to look forward to
coming from you if you got any games
you're going to be reviewing even the
cheese you can disclose
all that stuff yeah so you can find me
on twitter at thai guy travis
you can also add me on xbox playstation
or steam on tight travis
i am doing this new thing where i try to
play with a different group from the
community just randomly every week
and ask them what their bungie pleases
i'm sort of like crowdsourcing my
bungie complaints i've gotten some
really good ones from that so i have
like more than enough to work with but
i'm always happy to just
you know jump into a game of iron banner
with you if you see me online or
whatever so add me
um and then uh for ign i just got done
previewing an upcoming game that was
revealed at the
nintendo direct and also uh made an
appearance at the playstation event
today yeah what's that one i saw a tweet
it's called knockout city um it's a uh
competitive dodgeball game um i i did
the preview for it which you can read at
ign.com or uh watch the video on youtube
and uh i just i had a lot of fun with
that game so i i hope i'm gonna be able
to do the review
uh in may it comes out um but yeah
you can you can read about that game
there which i really enjoyed nice i saw
that one actually look like it could be
one of those
you know if it gets the right room to
breathe like maybe not as crazy as a
rocket league but still just looked like
it actually had this weird level of fun
yeah
yeah it kind of reminds me of like
monday night combat if you ever played
that xbox live arcade game back in the
day
it's yeah it like it reminds me of that
or
or rocket league or one of those just
like fun
you just hop in and just play a few
matches uh a type of game i saw that on
the playstation is it coming to
playstation as well
yeah it's actually coming to all
platforms and it has cross play and
cross progression on day one
which is kind of nuts um yeah so that
that was like one of the things was like
oh okay that's
like that's how games should be yeah i
mean they're doing it we're getting
we're getting there we're slowly getting
where like i play over here
gonna boot up my save up there doesn't
matter what you're playing it on so
eventually we will get there um now we
just need to get cross
buy handled because that's the one that
nobody's ever solved you know you have
to buy destiny on your platform
well that's the um that's how they stay
in business that's how bungie gets to
expand twice
over that's right that's right because
they got the game pass deal
i bet i bet you the game pass and the uh
netty's
google stadia deal they did yeah i bet
you those because
they were the first game on stadium i
bet they got so much money and now
stadia is gone and bungie's like
i got we got the money like you know so
yeah um we i'm yeah the future's crazy
for them but apparently with all of this
recently they seem to be doing fine
financially because i know there were
times like hey how's destiny they're
good they are totally fine they're very
good they are very good they are their
financial balance sheet is
um golden at this point whatever they're
doing it's working
um absolutely that's all i got you guys
know for me uh i will be playing
outriders tomorrow i will be on twitch
tomorrow doing that one
um it's fun so far honestly if you
haven't checked it out demo is free
the progress from the demo literally
will go into the full game
so if i play it on pc and then i pick it
up i get to start from chapter two and
just take my characters in so
if nothing else i would like this i know
it's not easy for games to do that
but they gave you basically the first
chapter and two
you try the demo and then you get to
move forward like the
the confidence behind them to do that is
what i think was really surprising
and so far i've just been having fun
it's a cool game so far so i'll be
playing that
you guys know i'll be playing destiny
and uh next week our podcast is gonna be
on
saturday just so you guys if you made it
this far and we're gonna have milan
games
um so just for those of you guys who are
actually in here great lore guy
awesome guy um so we're gonna have him
on a saturday night actually so it's
gonna be saturday at like
7 p.m eastern time or something like
that so
uh but for this episode 138 the special
request impromptu action with travis and
evontis thank you very much man for
coming in always a pleasure
can't wait to have you back uh and see
what other uh
insults come my way so it's always fun
to try and dodge them see what i can do
no i know just love just love hear high
five through the screen
bam cool all right for episode 138
february 25th thank you all very much
i'm gonna raid dcp
so guess what you're gonna go from one
podcast to another
so you guys have fun over there thank
you guys very much and we'll see you
soon
for this episode it has been the last
word